Und damit herzlich willkommen zum letzten Donnerstag im Monat, der traditionell dem Chaos Computer Club vorbehalten ist, der hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon Themen, die irgendwie mit dem seltsamen Internet das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr weggehen wird, zu tun haben, präsentiert. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Das Studio ist heute sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr voll. Wir verbringen also die erste halbe Stunde mit der Vorstellung. Naja, nicht ganz, aber trotzdem müssen wir jetzt sozusagen der Reihe nach vorgehen. In der Reihe ihres Erscheinens, also von links nach rechts hier in dem wirklich vollen Studio, ist da Elektra Wagenrath. Dann ist da Lasse, hallo, der Lasse, der das Mikrofon nicht aufmachen muss. Dann bitte zuhören, dass hallo. Hallo, hallo. Ah, sehr gut. Dann Emma Cienco, hallo. Und Monique Meisel. Und das sind vier Menschen von drei verschiedenen Organisationen. Das ist einmal Chaos Computer Club, also Elektra Wagenrath und Lasse. Dann Refuge Emancipation ist Emma Cienco und Monique Meisel ist mitbegründer der Initiative Freifunk und vom Förderverein Freien Netzwerk. Ah, sind doch vier Organisationen, sind alles wieder zusammen. Und wenn man das hört, also wenn wir uns sagen, jetzt sind die Namen und dann weiß man schon, worum es geht. Es geht heute um Flüchtlinge, ein Thema, das uns alle seit einer großen Zeit beschäftigt, seit einer langen Zeit. Und Technik. Warum das wichtig ist, was man macht, um Flüchtlinge und Hacker, um Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe. Das soll uns die nächsten zwei Stunden hier beschäftigen. Und es geht im allerweitesten Sinne darum, wie man den Menschen, die hier bei uns angekommen sind, Netz verschafft. Aber bevor man dazu kommt und was man alles machen muss, gibt es natürlich eine Vorgeschichte und eine Einordnung. Und auch das wollen wir heute hier leisten. Und liebe Anwesende, das ist natürlich die allererste Frage, wenn man das Flüchtlingsthema hört. Das ist sozusagen, da kommen halt Leute, die flüchten aus einer kriegszerstörten Umgebung und kommen quasi mit dem blanken Leben hier an. Gibt es nichts wichtigeres als gottverdammtes Internet?
Mit Sicherheit. Was zu essen, medizinische Erstversorgung, dann aber ganz schnell das Internet. Also wenn die Sachen geklärt sind, dann willst du als nächstes deine Familie Bescheid sagen, ob du gut angekommen bist, dich darum kümmern, was du mit den Behörden zu klären hast, Übersetzungsseiten suchen, so wie wir alle ohne Internet uns nackt fühlen, wenn wir rausgehen und unser Mobiltelefon vergessen haben. So gibt es den Flüchtlingen halt auch und nicht nur, wenn sie hier angekommen sind, sondern wie ich sehen durfte, auch schon auf dem Weg hierher ist das Mobiltelefon mindestens, aber auch Internet wichtig.
Dazu kommen wir gleich. Die aber sagen nur um diese Frage, die wahrscheinlich sagen, es ist ja Leuten aufregend gleich vorweg zu nehmen, es ist nicht so, dass das Internet das allerwichtigste ist, sondern das nackte Leben. Und sagen, die Grundbedürfnisse sind dann schon mit dabei. Aber bei Grundbedürfnissen ist dann schon auch relativ schnell die Kommunikation mit anderen Menschen. Und die ist halt heutzutage einfach digital. Lasse, du warst also nicht vor Ort im Sinne von in Syrien, aber fast.
Ja, nicht mal halbe Strecke würde ich sagen, aber genau.
Auf einer wichtigen Station, wenn man nach Europa will.
Genau, ich war sowohl in Budapest vor Ort und später noch mal in Röschke, das ja leider auch beides in den Medien war. Und in Röschke waren wir, weil aus einem Clubumfeld aus dem Berliner mehrere Leute gesagt haben, wir müssen jetzt was machen. Wir waren schon mal dort gewesen, haben eben gesehen, dass die Erstversorgung, sei es jetzt Wassernahrung, Klamotten, da hat sich die ungarische Zivilbevölkerung großartig gekümmert. Was halt keiner im Blick hatte, war, die brauchen Strom, die brauchen Internet. Es war so das erste, wenn mir Flüchtlinge begegnet sind, die gesehen haben, dass ich ein Smartphone habe, darf ich mal telefonieren. Was dann auch komisch war, wenn von deinem Telefon aus auf einmal Saudi-Arabien und ähnliche Länder angerufen werden. Anderes Thema.
Aber die Grundversorgung, also mit Lebensmittel, ist da auch geklärt oder gibt es da auch noch Mangel?
Kann man...
Geklärt ist schwierig. Es ist so, wie es sich da angefühlt hat, war es immer so, es entstehen neue Orte, wo viele Flüchtlinge aufschlagen. Dann ist da die ersten paar Tage eigentlich gar nichts geklärt. Das sind Freiwillige aus aller Herren Länder, die wirklich Einzelpersonen, eben nicht die großen Organisationen, die dann probieren, den Menschen dort zu helfen. Dann auch wirklich mit primär Essen, Unterkunft, warmen Klamotten, Schuhe. Ganz wichtiges Thema immer wieder. Und dann kommen die großen Organisationen meistens so drei, vier Tage später rein. Also in Röschke war es so, wir waren da glaube ich an Tag fünf oder sechs, nachdem es in den Medien war. Und die Helfer sagten uns alle, jetzt ist gut, jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Das sah für unsere Verhältnisse ganz schön übel dort aus und war unorganisiert. Aber es gab eben eine medizinische Erstversorgung inzwischen vom UNHCR. Die großen, bekannten Organisationen waren inzwischen angekommen. Aber die brauchen halt immer zwei, drei, vier Tage. Und dann kümmern sie sich natürlich auch primär um Verpflegung, übernehmen das sozusagen von den vorherigen Helfern, die Lebensmittelversorgung und medizinische Versorgung.
Und warum genau warst du da oder mit wem warst du da? Was habt ihr da gemacht?
Wir waren da, weil wir in Berlin alle das Gefühl hatten, doof vor unseren Fernsehern zu sitzen. Und anders als sonst, wenn man solche menschlichen Tragödien sieht, die dann weit weg passieren, warst diesmal sehr, sehr nah dran und einfach eine Autofahrt entfernt sozusagen. Und wir haben dann relativ spontan im bekannten Kreis rumgefragt, wer hätte dann Lust, was dazu zu geben, wenn wir da jetzt mit einem größeren Transporter runterfahren. Haben jetzt keinen 7, 5 Tonner voll gemacht, aber eben einen T5 bis unter das Dach und haben dann halt verschiedenste Dinge gekauft. Auch Sachen wie zum Beispiel Zelte, die jetzt auch nicht selbstverständlich von der Hilfsorganisation bereitgestellt werden, weil die haben auch einen anderen Fokus, ist ja auch richtig so. Aber wir haben uns eben auch darum gekümmert, Mehrfachstockdosen dort runterzubringen. Wir haben Transformatoren mitgenommen, die 12 Volt auf 230 umsetzen. Das ist jetzt nicht die idealste Lösung. Man hätte gerne einen Generator gehabt, um dort Strom anzubieten, aber so hat man da unten dann eben Strom anbieten können, das an Leute dort unten weitergeben, die jetzt damit Flüchtlingen, die ankommen, die Möglichkeit geben, einfach nur ihre Geräte zu laden. Also die wollen da ja auch nicht bleiben. Die Flüchtlinge kommen an Orten wie Röschke an, wollen jetzt einmal schlafen, wenn sie nicht vertrieben werden, neue Kraft schaffen, ihre Geräte laden, wenn sie Glück haben, können sie einen Telefonanruf absetzen und dann wollen die weiter.
Jetzt ist ja auch hier immer diskutiert worden, die haben halt alle Smartphones. Das war dann auch so ein Argument von Flüchtlingsgegnern. Die, die Smartphone haben, sind ja quasi reich, was natürlich totaler Quatsch ist. Wie hast du das da erlebt? Wie verbreitet ist das und was machen die damit?
Es ist schon sehr verbreitet, jetzt alle würde ich nicht unterstreichen. Smartphone ist auch das eine. Du brauchst auch einen Vertrag, der nach Europa jetzt noch funktioniert. Also ich habe sehr oft erlebt, dass sie Telefone hatten, aber einfach gar keinen Vertrag, der jetzt hier funktionieren würde und nicht mehr telefonieren konnten, deswegen auf WLAN angewiesen waren. Ich habe mehrfach erlebt und auch von anderen Freunden erfahren, dass Facebook-Anrufe eine Selbstverständlichkeit sind. So halten die untereinander Kontakt. Es gab in den deutschen Medien gerade auch mehrere Beispiele, wo Kinder hier angekommen sind, die bei einem der Grenzübertritte von ihren Eltern getrennt wurden und dann die Reise alleine fortgesetzt haben. Die haben keine Kontakte mehr in Syrien. Du hast halt auf einmal niemanden mehr, den du anrufen kannst und sagen kannst, hier, wenn meine Eltern sich bei dir melden, sag mal, ich bin dort. Und Mobiltelefone mit einer bestehenden Nummer, weil hilft ja nichts, ein Mobiltelefon zu haben, wenn du nicht die Nummer deiner Eltern weißt, sind schon eine sehr entscheidende, wichtige Sache. Und die Flüchtlinge, die das haben, die legen dann natürlich auch immer wieder Wert drauf, das nutzen zu können, um sich so untereinander zu connecten.
Und da ist tatsächlich Facebook die Plattform? Also quasi das große universale Telefonbuch?
Das ist das, was ich am allermeisten erlebt habe. Ich hab auch mal Twitter erlebt, aber es war wirklich Facebook, Facebook, Facebook. Beim ersten Mal war ich ehrlich gesagt sehr überrascht. Mir war es nicht bewusst, dass man mit Facebook telefonieren kann. Auf einmal wurde mir da ein Telefon ins Gesicht gehalten mit Facebook drauf, weil es dann halt eine Nummer, ein Facebook-Account war, wo der Mensch dahinter in Deutschland saß. Und sie sind auch sehr, sehr solidarisch untereinander, die Syrer. Also das war in dem Fall ein Nachbar von vor 20 Jahren, den er angerufen hat. Und die haben sich aus Deutschland gekümmert, wo jetzt Leute hin können. Und da wurden ganz viele Nachbarschaftsstrukturen aus längst vergangener Zeit sozusagen wieder aktiviert. Und die wurde mitgefiebert aus Deutschland und probiert zu helfen. Um sozusagen das auch koordinieren kann man jetzt gar nicht sagen. Es gibt nicht die Koordinatoren. Aber die Sachen sprechen sich sehr schnell rum. Das haben wir ja auch gesehen, als dann Ungarn dichtgemacht hat, wie superschnell die ganzen Menschen über Kroatien ausgewichen sind. Und da tragen genauso Facebook und solche sozialen Netzwerke eben dazu bei, dass sich die Informationen weiter tragen. Auch zu den Leuten, die dann kein Smartphone haben.
Ich muss mal eine vielleicht dispektivische Frage an der Stelle stellen. Aber ist das eigentlich, wenn man so aus dem Haka-Umfeld kommt und ich sage jetzt mal übertrieben sein, ein Leben lang an Open Source Alternativen zu proprietären Angeboten arbeitet und dann stellt man fest, ok, dieses schlimme Facebook, was man eigentlich nie haben wollte, hat es irgendwie geschafft, eine Kommunikationsplattform zu werden, die wirklich in jeder Situation benutzt werden kann. Ist das komisch erstmal?
Da war ich glaube ich schon immer zu doll Pragmatiker. Zu streiten mich da eher mit meinen eigenen Leuten teilweise, wenn ich vielleicht jetzt auch der Falsche war. Offensichtlich haben sie was richtig gemacht und auch wenn ich dann doch zur Fraktion gehöre, die Facebook kompliziert findet, scheint es so einfach und funktionierend zu sein, dass es für diese Menschen sehr sehr häufig genutzt wird. Und jetzt auch durch alle Schichten hindurch. Vom Ingenieur, das muss man bei den syrischen Flüchtlingen gerade halt auch sehen. Ich hab da Menschen kennengelernt, die waren Informatiker, Ingenieure, Mathematiker, Ärzte. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, wenn Eritreer die Leute vom Land dort fliehen, die vielleicht noch nicht viel mit Technik gesehen haben, sondern einfach ein völlig anderes Niveau. Das war, ja, man dachte eher, oh mein Gott, das hätte jetzt auch ich sein können. Einfach weil die Lebensläufe an vielen Punkten eher sehr ähnlich waren.
Ich glaube, das ist eh was, was man sich der Flüchtlingsdebatte immer wieder vor's Auge führen sollte. Dass man nur Glück hatte, wo man geboren ist. Und im Prinzip könnte man selber auch sein. Ihr seid dann da sozusagen runtergefahren, seid dann wieder zurückgekommen. Und die Situation, über die wir heute sprechen, ist ja tatsächlich die in Deutschland. Aber bevor wir denn dazu kommen, wie man da internet hinkriegt, wie ist denn da sozusagen, habt ihr da auch was erlebt? Wie ist denn da die Situation, wenn hier, also man hat es in Berlin gehört, das Lagiso ist ja das große, das große Thema immer gewesen, das große Ding. Wie ist die Situation hier, wenn die Leute dann angekommen sind in Deutschland?
Ja genau, zum Beispiel diese Lagiso-Situation, da standen die Leute ja dann einen langen Schlang über Tage hinweg an, um ihre Unterlagen abzugeben, um sich registrieren zu lassen. Das war eine katastrophale Situation. Und auch da waren natürlich wieder Nachbarn die Schnellsten, die geholfen haben, bevor dort irgendwie Organisationen, also im Prinzip das gleiche Bild zum Zuge kamen. Nachbarn haben geholfen, haben Essen gebracht, haben Kleiderspenden organisiert und so weiter und so fort. Auch da gibt es das Problem, dass es keinen Internetzugang gibt. Aber da konnten die Freifunker mit ihren Kontakten dann auch helfen, dann auch da Kommunikation möglich zu machen, wie auch an vielen, vielen anderen Stellen.
Aber kannst du die Situation da noch vor Ort noch mal ein bisschen genauer beschreiben? Also wie das da ist, muss man schlafen da Menschen übereinander auf der blanken Straße?
Ja, tatsächlich haben die da zum Teil eben, es war ja auch hier und da noch recht warm, irgendwie unter Bäumen gesessen, nach Schatten gesucht irgendwie. Die Kinder wurden irgendwo, sind irgendwie rumgelaufen. Die Menschen haben in der Schlange gestanden. Man will auch seinen Platz dann nicht aufgeben. Das heißt, du stehst dann dort und wartest einfach und ja, tagelang.
Also ist so ein bisschen an unserer Aufmerksamkeit in der Szene vorbei gegangen, weil wir zufälligerweise genau in der Zeit ein Camp hatten, wo wir alle hin verschwunden sind. Genau in den Tagen haben in Berlin auf der Straße Flüchtlinge übernachtet, die nicht mal in eine Erstaufnahme-Unterkunft kamen, weil LaGue so überfüllt war und sie einfach nicht darauf vorbereitet waren. Was immer wieder eigentlich der Wahnsinn ist, weil das ist irgendwie keine Entwicklung, die vorgestern entstanden ist. Das war lange, lange absehbar und es hat sich halt niemand, weder auf Bundes- noch anderer Ebene vorbereitet gehabt und Berlin halt eben auch nicht.
Und ist das jetzt immer noch so oder hat sich das mittlerweile wieder ein bisschen entspannt?
Es hat sich mittlerweile entspannt. Die Leute sind eigentlich nicht mehr auf der Straße. Es sind ja Unterkünfte wie Pilze aus dem Boden geschossen worden. Es wurden Tonhallen, leerstehende Gebäude, alles Mögliche jetzt akquiriert, Container und so weiter, wo die jetzt untergekommen sind.
Wobei ich einschränken würde, der Punkt hat sich jetzt entspannt. Medizinische Erstversorgung und all die anderen Probleme, zu Internet kommen wir noch, die sozusagen mit dranhängen. Da sehe ich jetzt noch nicht so viel Entspannung. Aber ja, im Moment wäre mir auch nicht bewusst, dass noch Leute auf der Straße schlafen müssen in Berlin.
Okay, also sagen, die ganz schlimmen Dinge sind geklärt und es muss niemand mehr konkret Angst zu haben, keine Dachbein im Kopf zu haben oder um sein Leben.
Das ist eine offene Wunde und nicht versorgt werden.
Aber ist es noch so schlimm, dass das nicht passiert?
Es ist wohl, was ich zumindest noch vor drei, vier Tagen gehört habe. Ich habe da eine Frau kennengelernt, die hat sich dem Thema sehr angenommen, obwohl sie gar nicht aus der Ecke kommt. Die hat Horrorgeschichten erzählt. Die probieren alle, das muss man immer dazu sagen. Die Ärzte melden sich freiwillig, um Sonderschichten zu machen. Es ist Goodwill überall da. Aber es ist einfach auch eine große Aufgabe gerade, wo es auch nichts bringt, zu sagen, Behörden, ihr müsst manchmal, sondern jetzt einfach alle anpacken müssen.
In dem Zusammenhang noch mit der medizinischen Erstversorgung tatsächlich wurde mir erzählt, dass man sich als Geflüchteter ja auch sogenannte Scheine holen kann, um dann zu einem Arzt zu gehen. Das Problem daran ist, dann entscheidet ein Sachbearbeiter, ob dir dieser Schein so steht. Und die Ärzte wissen nichts davon und weisen die Leute ab.
Das kannst du auch nur machen, wenn du eine Erstaufnahme, wenn du dich überhaupt anmelden konntest, was halt die auch wieder überführt sind.
Also auch da gibt es sozusagen noch dramatische Situationen, dass da einfach wirklich Begleiter mitgehen müssen zu den Ärzten und da irgendwie vermitteln müssen und denen sozusagen klarmachen müssen, bitte versorgt die mal.
Puh, trotzdem dann schon die Frage Internet. Könntest du dir nochmal ein bisschen genauer spezifizieren, warum jetzt gerade Internet, warum stellen wir nicht einfach ein Festnetztelefon hin? Also was genau ist das Ziel, wenn man sagt, die müssen jetzt alle irgendwie ins Netz kommen?
Na also im Netz, da ist ja neben dem Kommunikationsaspekt auch der Informationsaspekt und das Problem am Telefon ist ein bisschen, dass es da einfach Roaminggebühren gibt, dass das unheimlich teuer ist in diese Länder zu telefonieren und dass es da dann einfacher ist, das Internet eben zu nutzen und die Kommunikationskanäle dort und auch günstiger. Und wie gesagt, über die Kommunikation hinaus kommt die Information, kommt die Möglichkeit zu übersetzen mit entsprechenden Apps oder Webseiten. Es kommt auch die Möglichkeit, die Zeit zu nutzen, um sich weiterzubilden, um die Sprache zu lernen und nicht zuletzt auch um die Zeit totzuschlagen, die da einfach ins Land geht, während du wartest und nicht arbeiten darfst.
Ganz simples Beispiel, noch früher von eben schon mal, wenn du hier ankommst, unterwegs deine Familie verloren hast, selbst wenn du eine Nummer, da geht dann vielleicht auch mal niemand dran sozusagen, falls sie ihr Handy überhaupt noch haben. Teilweise wird sie ihn unterwegs abgenommen, solche Beispiele gab es auch. Dann ist die Telefonnummer weg. Was da bleibt, ist ein Facebook-Account, wo ich eine Nachricht hinterlassen kann, wo ich bin. Also das ist wirklich nicht irgendwann Internet, sondern teilweise interessieren die sich ja nicht mal für ihre eigenen Verletzungen, weil erst mal willst du wissen, wo dein Kind ist oder wo deine Eltern sind. Also das steht schon sehr, sehr weit oben in der Prioritätenliste und ist nicht nach dem Motto, ich muss jetzt erst mal mich eine Woche wieder aufpäppeln und gut essen und dann brauche ich Internet. Nee, die brauchen unmittelbar Internet.
Wie ist das denn jetzt mit Internet? Kann man sagen, okay, wir stellen dir einen Router hin und dann fällt der net raus. Fertig. Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so einfach. Also A, was bedeutet das so in Größenordnungen? Wie viele Leute muss man da pro Auffanglager oder Unterbringung überhaupt versorgen? Und B, wie macht man das? Also was ist denn konkret dafür nötig? Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr als nur wir legen da ein WLAN hin.
Na ja, im Zweifel ist es tatsächlich so einfach. Wir legen da einfach mal ein WLAN hin, weil wir es können. Aber es ist sehr unterschiedlich, wie groß diese Aufnahmestellen sind. Es gibt auch Unterschiede zwischen Dauerunterkünften oder Erstaufnahmestellen, Notunterkünften. Es gibt ganz kleine, da sind vielleicht nur 100 Leute und dann gibt es irgendwie große, da sind bis zu 1700 Leute. Das ist das Größte, was ich bis jetzt gehört habe.
Also Monique und ich hatten interessanterweise die Diskussion auch kurz bevor ich nach Ungarn gefahren bin, weil wir uns dort die Situation angucken wollten, uns überlegt hatten, wie kann man es machen. Ich habe dort auch Menschen getroffen von Greenpeace Ungarn interessanterweise, die Strom und Internet zur Verfügung gestellt haben, den Flüchtlingen in Röschke. Und stellte sich dann raus, wenn aber 3000 Flüchtlinge in einer Zelle sind auf dem Acker, dann bricht halt alles zusammen. Wir mussten jetzt erstmal lernen, was sind denn überhaupt die Stufen, welche Probleme können denn da auftauchen. Weil wenn dir die ganze Funkzelle zusammenbricht, dann hilft dir auch dein LTE-Router nicht weiter, mit dem du sie hättest theoretisch versorgen können.
Und gibt es dafür schon eine Lösung?
Ich wollte nur sagen, die größte Einrichtung, von der ich weiß, da sind 2000 Leute. Und die zu versorgen, das ist schon ähnlich komplex, wie wenn man jetzt eine größere Konferenz versorgen will. Also mit einem Accesspoint ist es da nicht getan. Mit einem Accesspoint kann man 25 Clients gleichzeitig versorgen.
Okay, sagen wir, da ist dann... Also ich vermute, es multipliziert sich auch nicht einfach. Also man sagt dann nicht, okay, dann 2000 durch 25 so viele Accesspoints stellen wir da hin, sondern da ist noch ein bisschen mehr Technik dahinter. Ja, nein, vielleicht?
Doch, das wäre die Vorgehensweise, dass man mehrere Accesspoints hinstellt, womöglich die Reichweite beschränkt. Also dass man halt wie im zellularen Netzwerk von Smartphones oder von GSM kleinere Zellen macht, damit man es verteilen kann. Aber man muss natürlich auch erstmal die Bandbreite da hinkriegen. Und das ist auch erstmal ein Problem.
Das ist genau die nächste Frage, die ich stellen wollte. Jetzt braucht man ja sozusagen, also wenn dann alle Wedern haben, gut und schön, dann müssen die auch irgendwie in das Internet rein. Weiß ich nicht, ich hab zu Hause einen VDS 1150, hat das auch jede Unterbringungseinrichtung und dann checkt man das da ran oder wie läuft das?
Definitiv nicht. Teilweise gibt es keine Internetanschlüsse oder die sind den Büromitarbeitern dieser Heime vorbehalten, weil sie vielleicht auch nur schmalbandig sind. Es ist auch da wirklich total unterschiedlich. Wir versuchen da eben, wenn Internetzugang vorhanden ist, den dann mittels unserer Router zu öffnen, wenn der breitbandig genug ist. Alternativ können wir auch von außen versorgen. Freifunk hat ja ein eigenes Netzwerk, in dem Internet vorhanden ist und können dann teilweise über Richtfunk in Richtung dieser Heimestrahlen und auf die Art versorgen. Oder über Nachbarn. Das heißt, wir finden Nachbarn in der Nähe, die dann auch mittels Freifunk ihre Internetanschlüsse öffnen und in der näheren Umgebung dann eben Internet zur Verfügung stellen.
Das Problem, was du hast, ist halt vielschichtig. Du hast das technische Problem, überhaupt dort Internet hinzubekommen, irgendwo im Wald, wo teilweise Flüchtlingsunterkünfte sind, wo halt gar keine andere Infrastruktur vorhanden ist. Das kriegt man alles gelöst. Dann hast du aber natürlich auch immer das politische Problem, weil es in Deutschland einfach nicht geregelt ist, dass alle Flüchtlinge Internet bekommen, sozusagen. Sondern das ist Sache der Kommunen. Das kann dann die Welzen das auf die privaten Betreiber ab. Da gehen wir nachher auch noch ein bisschen genauer ein, wo da die Probleme im Argen liegen. Aber es ist einfach eine sehr, sehr komplexe Situation mit allen möglichen Beteiligten, sowohl technischen als auch politischen Problemen, was man leider nicht mal einfach abräumen und lösen kann. Es gibt nicht die eine technische Lösung und wahrscheinlich auch nicht die eine politische Forderung, die man mal eben umsetzt. Aber da erfahren wir nachher noch mehr zu.
Ganz kurz noch dazu. Tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass die Freifunker schon seit langer, langen Jahren mit solchen, mit WLAN-Setups Erfahrungen sammeln und wir bis jetzt schon 100, über 100 Unterkünfte in ganz Deutschland spontan versorgen konnten. Also eben auf die eben genannten Weisen. Also das ist schon möglich. Es ist dann vielleicht nicht immer die tollste Bandbreite. Es ist dann noch immer nicht die beste Variante oder so. Aber zumindest, um überhaupt erstmal was anbieten zu können.
Aber das ist dann sozusagen Freifunker? Das heißt, das sind Leute, die machen das ehrenamtlich ohne Bezahlung und sozusagen mit dem, was sie vorfinden, was ihnen bereitgestellt wird. Das ist halt nicht von einer offiziellen Stelle gemacht. Oder auch nicht von einer größeren Firma?
Nein, absolut nicht. Freifunk hat ja in Deutschland mittlerweile weit über 200 lokale Gruppen. Ja, aber da hat man schon auch eine Schlagkraft, wenn dann sozusagen überall dort, wo Flüchtlingsheime aufpoppen, die Freifunker anfangen, sich zu engagieren, hingehen, sprechen, Lösungen suchen.
Was ich meinte, das sind alles Menschen, die das jetzt aus der eigenen Tasche, aus der eigenen Motivation machen. Und das ist niemand, der eigentlich entweder Geld damit verdient, Internet bereitzustellen oder der offiziell zuständig ist für solche Unterkünfte, kümmert sich oder kann sich da schnell darum kümmern.
Die Freifunker arbeiten alle ehrenamtlich und die Hardware wird gespendet oder von den Leuten gekauft zurzeit.
Also wir haben zurzeit die Situation, dass ganz viele Leute sich zivilgesellschaftlich engagieren und viele haben dann auch die Idee, ich bringe den Leuten Internet. Die kommen dann bei uns an, am Mittwoch in der Seabways und fragen uns, wie sie das technisch auf die Reihe kriegen. Also sie haben die Idee, da gibt es Freifunk und ich kann helfen, das zu verbreiten. Und ich helfe jetzt den Leuten da in diesen Flüchtlingsaufnahme-Lage.
Das heißt also, die, was wir in den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen schon gehört haben, dass das zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement zur Flüchtlingshilfe groß ist, gilt auch in dem digitalen Bereich, gilt auch dahingehend, dass sozusagen digitale Kommunikation ermöglicht wird. Wir reden gleich über den Verein Refugee Emancipation, wo es genau darum geht, sozusagen das großflächiger zu machen und auch langfristiger. Vorher gibt es aber die Nachrichtenwörter und Verkehr. Und davor gibt es noch einen Song, den die verehrten Gäste mitgebracht haben. Das ist ein Atelier von But Alive.
Yo! Moderiert von Katrin Thüring und Chris Goose. Samstag, 31. Oktober im Admiralspalast Berlin.
Relativ talentiert, organisiert.
Von... Die Bundesländer sollen vom Bund offenbar mehr Geld zur Bewältigung der Flüchtlingskrise erhalten. Wie Bundeskanzlerin Merkel am Abend mitteilte, will sich der Bund monatlich mit 670 Euro pro Flüchtling an den Kosten beteiligen. Die Unterstützung soll vom Tag der Erstregistrierung bis zum Abschluss des Asylverfahrens geleistet werden. Außerdem sollen 500 Millionen Euro für den sozialen Wohnungsbau und weitere 350 Millionen Euro für die Betreuung unbegleiteter minderjähriger Flüchtlinge bereitgestellt werden. Ungarn schottet sich in der Flüchtlingskrise weiter ab. Jetzt wurde auch an der Grenze zu Slowenien damit begonnen, einen Zaun zu bauen. Das berichtete die staatliche ungarische Nachrichtenagentur MIT. Erst vor kurzem hatte die Regierung in Budapest den Bau von Zäunen an der Grenze zu Kroatien und Rumänien angekündigt. Die Übergänge zu Serbien sind bereits abgeriegelt. In Saudi-Arabien hat sich eines der größten Unglücke der vergangenen Jahre während der islamischen Pilgerfahrt Hatsch ereignet. Bei einer Massenpanik in der Nähe von Mekka sind mehr als 700 Menschen ums Leben gekommen, weitere 800 Menschen wurden verletzt. Der Iran warf den Saudi-Arabischen Behörden schlechte Organisation vor. Der Saudi-Arabische Gesundheitsminister hingegen machte fehlende Disziplin bei den Pilgern für das Unglück verantwortlich. Sie hätten sich nicht an vereinbarte Uhrzeiten gehalten. Papst Franziskus hat im US-Parlament die Abschaffung der Todesstrafe gefordert. Jedes Leben sei heilig, sagte das katholische Kirchnummerhaupt vor dem Kongress in Washington. Der Papst kritisierte auch die US-Waffenexporte. Waffen verursachten unsägliches Leid. Sie würden nur exportiert, um Geld zu machen. Franziskus sprach als erster Papst vor dem US-Kongress. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, die liegen in Berlin-Triptow bei 8 Grad, in Wilmersdorf sind es 14 Grad, in Küre 10 Grad, in Frankfurt an der Oder 11 Grad und Prenzlau und Wiesenburg melden jeweils 13 Grad. In der Nacht wird es locker bewölkt, bleibt aber meistens trocken und erst am Morgen hin kann es etwas regnen bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 11 und 7 Grad. Morgen müsst ihr dann mit ein paar Meerwolken und teilweise auch Regen in Berlin und Brandenburg rechnen. Die Temperaturen sind ähnlich wie heute, 16 bis 19 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, in Mitte und Kreuzberg müsst ihr mit Behinderungen wegen einer Demo rechnen. Die Strecke führt von Unter den Linden über Friedrich, Koch und Wilhelmstraße bis zur Stresemannstraße. Und nach Brandenburg auf der A13 dreht es in Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Löbenau und Duben blockiert ein kaputter Laster die Standspur. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, also der Sendung, wo der Chaos Computer Club und Anverwandte, befreundete Organisationen das Studio besetzen, um über Themen ihrer Wahl zu reden, die meistens mit irgendwas Digitalem zu tun haben. Heute geht es darum, wie man Flüchtlingen digitale Kommunikation ermöglichen. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde erklärt, warum das wichtig ist. Direkt nach, wir haben genug zu essen und zu trinken, ein Dach über dem Kopf und sind gesundheitlich einigermaßen versorgt. Und wir wollen jetzt zu einem Projekt kommen, was sich damit beschäftigt auch. Das ist Refugee Emancipation. Und da begrüße ich nochmal ganz herzlich Ima Tchenko. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ja, hallo.
Und Elektra Wagenrath wird auch mal etwas dazu erzählen in der halben Stunde. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal.
Das mach ich womöglich.
Und außerdem sind noch Lasse und Monique da, die jetzt wahrscheinlich in der halben Stunde ihr nichts sagen werden, aber trotzdem nochmal Hallo und guten Abend. So, Emma, du bist von Refugee Emancipation, was genau ist das eigentlich?
Refugees Emancipation ist eine selbstorganisierte Flüchtlingsverein und es betreibt kostenlos Internet-Cafés in Flüchtlingsheimen in Brandenburg und Berlin. Und in diese Räume haben Flüchtlinge Zugang zum Internet, aber es ist auch wie ein Lernort, also sie haben nicht nur Zugang zum Internet, sie haben diese Möglichkeit mit Freiwilligen von der Zivilgesellschaft Computer-Kurs zu machen, zur Allgemeinorientierung. Dann haben wir Sachen wie, wie man online Deutsch lernen kann und dann haben wir auch so Kinderprojekte, also Flüchtlingskinder, die gerade in die Schule kommen, auch Nachhilfe von diesen Freiwilligen.
Das ist ja nicht ein Projekt, was jetzt gerade erst entstanden ist. Es gibt schon eine Weile. Wie hat das angefangen? Wie ist es dazu überhaupt gekommen? Wie bist du dazu gekommen?
Also das Projekt ist vor ca. 14 Jahren, hat vor ca. 14 Jahren angefangen.
Vor 14 Jahren?
Und es ist initiiert von ein paar Flüchtlinge, die damals nach Deutschland, also Asyl beantragt haben. Und als sie nach Deutschland gekommen sind, also sie haben diese, sag ich mal, Illusion gehabt, dass Deutschland also eine entwickelte Welt, sie werden dann also alles dann bekommen, also Studium, also Arbeit und so weiter. Und als sie dann Asyl beantragt haben, sind sie in diese sogenannte Flüchtlingsheim oder Übergangsvornheim geschickt worden. Sie waren oder sie sind immer noch in Brandenburg, sehr weit entfernte Orte und sie sind quasi wie soziale Quarantäne-Orte. Und sie haben kein Recht auf Arbeit, sie dürfen nicht studieren. Und danach gab es dann diese Residenzpflicht. Und alle diese legale Schwierigkeiten haben diese Flüchtlinge gepackt, so ein Initiativ zu organisieren. Das heißt damals Initiativ Berlin Brandenburg. Und diese Flüchtlinge haben versucht, ihre Legale oder ihre Schwierigkeiten an der Zivilgesellschaft zu erklären, was sie dann erleben in diesen Flüchtlingsheimen.
Ich will kurz noch eine Sache sagen. Erklären, Residenzpflicht bedeutet ja, dass man quasi in so einem Heim ist und dann da nicht aber weg darf.
In so ein Kreise. Vielleicht noch so ein Kreise und da darf man nicht weg.
Das Ziel war sozusagen, da Kommunikation hinzubringen oder eine Möglichkeit sich Gehör zu verschaffen.
Ja genau, nicht nur Kommunikation, also Information. Und dann das Wichtigste, das war, Sie haben festgestellt, um sich besser zu erklären oder sich besser verstehen zu können, sollen Sie dann sich bilden, also sich selbst bilden, weil Sie kein Studium, Sie dürfen nicht dann studieren. Dann haben Sie gedacht, Sie sollen dann Wege finden, wie Sie alternative Bildungsmöglichkeiten haben können. Und das Internet hat diese Wege, das war das beste Wege. Dann haben Sie dann Wege oder diese Refugees-Emancipation kreiert. Sie haben dann Internet und diese Informationen in Flüchtlingsheimen gepackt. Das erste war in Potsdam und in diesen Raumen, das war wie ein Lähenort. Dann haben Sie sich selber gebildet mit Internet und alles, was Internet anbieten kann.
Wo seid ihr jetzt gerade, an wie vielen Orten?
Ich glaube, 2001 hat es angefangen in Potsdam und dann hat andere Heimbetreiber, zum Beispiel in Prenzlau, Bad Belsig, Lückenwalde, Rattenau, Riffeln, Eisenhütenstadt, haben die anderen von dem Projekt gehört und dann haben sie Refugees-Emancipation angerufen und dann haben sie auch dort das Projekt auch angefangen.
Du hast auch am Anfang eine Rolle damit gespielt oder hast du das mitbekommen, oder wie war das?
Um das Jahr 1999, 2000 habe ich angefangen, bei so einer Aktivistengruppe mitzumachen, die nannten sich Low-Tech und wir haben so ein kostenloses, alternatives Internet-Café betrieben in Friedrichshain. Und wir haben das als unsere Mission betrachtet, den Menschen zu helfen, damit irgendwie mit sicherer Kommunikation Leuten eine Stimme zu geben, die in der Gesellschaft unterrepräsentiert sind, also zum Beispiel gerade die Flüchtlinge mit ihrer Residenzpflicht, die sozial isoliert leben in diesen Heimen, Menschen Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten zu geben über Internet und Computer. Und wir waren so Open Source Evangelisten, wir haben so Leuten beigebracht, wie Malinux installiert und Crypto-Parties, würde man es heute nennen, damals gab es noch kein Wort dafür. Wir haben halt gespendete Computer aufgearbeitet und haben die dann an Refugees Emancipation übergeben.
Und dann sozusagen war das dann am Anfang oder ist das so eine stetige Zusammenarbeit geworden?
Leider hat das Low-Tech irgendwann geendet und ich hab dann angefangen Freifunk vor allem zu machen. Also der Grundstein für meine Beschäftigung und auch vieles, was ich gelernt habe, habe ich damals Low-Tech von anderen Hackerlern gelernt. Und wir sind dann irgendwann, was wir damals gemacht haben, uns darauf zu konzentrieren, anderen Leuten kostenloses Internet zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das wurde immer weniger wichtig für die normale Gesellschaft, aber immer wichtiger für die Flüchtlinge.
Das heißt, du bist jetzt wieder dabei, was du vor 14 Jahren schon mal angefangen hattest? Mehr oder weniger?
Ja, irgendwie wirft es mich daraufhin wieder zurück.
Ist das eigentlich eine Geschichte, die jetzt selber läuft? Ihr habt alles da, also auch an Ressourcen und Leuten? Oder braucht es da immer noch Hilfe?
Auf jeden Fall, als eine selbstorganisierte Flüchtlingsverein haben wir sehr, sehr wenige Ressourcen. Also wir brauchen immer noch Freiwillige, die in der Internet-Cafés gehen können und dort Computer-Courses zu geben oder Allgemeinorientierung. Weil wenn die Flüchtlinge neulich ankommen, dann meistens wissen sie nicht, also zum Beispiel, was ist die Unterschied zwischen Ausländerbehörde und die Polizei oder die Unterschied zwischen den Behörden. Also es gibt allgemeine Informationen und sie werden auch gezeigt, wie man im Internet zum Beispiel einen Arzt suchen kann, einen Termin machen kann oder wie man online Deutsch lernen kann. Also alle diese sehr wichtigen Dinge, sie werden von der Freiwilligen in diese Internet-Cafés dann an die Flüchtlinge gegeben. Also deswegen brauchen wir immer Leute, die sich freiwilliger engagieren in diese Internet-Cafés dann.
Und ist das dann so, dass ihr da Leute sucht, die irgendwie jetzt auch total firm und gebildet sind in diesen ganzen konkreten Fragen oder ist es schon auch hilfreich, wenn man sich irgendwie halbwegs mit Computern auskennt und vor allen Dingen halt die Sprache, die hier so wichtig ist, spricht?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also die Leute, die auch ein bisschen Ahnung haben. Nicht spezielle Computerkenntnis, aber so allgemein, weil es gibt viele Flüchtlinge, die nur so ganz einfache Sachen dann brauchen, wie man ein E-Mail aufmachen kann und so weiter. Also muss man nicht ein Spezialist in Computer sein zum Beispiel.
Ich hab im Vorfeld einen Zeitungsartikel gelesen, da ging es auch um dieses Thema Internet für Flüchtlinge und da war glaube ich auch ein Betreiber von so einem WLAN-Café an einer Unterbringung da und der meinte, eigentlich ist es besser, wenn es diesen Ort gibt und nicht irgendwie für alle WLAN, weil die Leute dann zusammenkommen. Gibt es da für euch irgendwie Prioritäten? Also wollt ihr lieber einen festen Ort, wo es Internet gibt oder soll möglichst Internet für alle da sein?
Also von unserer Erfahrung ist es besser, wenn es so einen Ort in Flüchtlingen Heime gibt. Also dann haben die Flüchtlinge schon mal Internetzugang, wo sie wohnen und wir haben immer diese Erfahrung. Also es ist besser, wenn sie zusammenkommen in diese Räume, wo sie lernen und wo dann gibt es so einen Austausch zwischen den Flüchtlingen. Dann gibt es nicht mehr diese Isolation, dass jeder in seinem Zimmer bleibt und vielleicht 24 Stunden Downloads macht. Aber sie kommen dann zusammen in diese Räume, dann tauschen sie dann Erfahrungen und dann gibt es diese interkulturelle Mischung, die sehr positiv ist.
Es geht dabei denke ich auch immer um Information eigentlich, also es herrschen viele Gerüchte, habe ich mehrfach gehört in den Unterkünften. Dann erzählen dir Leute auf einmal, geh bloß nicht zu diesem Termin, weil wenn du da hingehst, passiert dir was Schlimmes, aber es ist jetzt genau der Termin, der wichtig gewesen wäre. Und da eben einen Anlaufpunkt zu haben, wie dieses Internet-Café von Flüchtlingen für Flüchtlinge, hat man geschafft, auch Vertrauen, dass da wirkliche Informationen vorliegen. Und auch Vertrauen, ich weiß aus eurer Geschichte, dass zum Beispiel auch Wert auf ungefiltertes Internet gelegt wird und dass die Betreiber nicht in diese Räume einfach reingehen. Also Refugee-Emancipation hat da sehr, sehr viel mehr geleistet, als nur ein paar Computer aufzustellen, sondern sich eben auch auf die Hinterbeine gestellt und gesagt, okay, dann wollen wir aber nicht an euer Behördennetz, was gefiltert ist. Und auf einmal kannst du nicht mehr nach Syrien telefonieren, wo deine Familie hängt, weil der Filter jetzt findet, das ist doof.
Es gab ja diese unsägliche Äußerung in Stuttgart von der Verantwortlichen, von der Kommune. Man könne den Flüchtlingen kein Internet geben, solange nicht gewährleistet sei, dass es Hasenrein sei. Also was da den Flüchtlingen angeboten wird.
Was ist denn Hasenrein, will ich jetzt wissen?
Ich weiß nicht, ich müsste darüber nachdenken und ich gehöre nicht zu den Leuten, die gerne nachdenken.
Wo kommt eigentlich sozusagen die Technik her, die ihr da verwendet? Also wo kriegt ihr das ungefilterte Internet her und wo kommen die Geräte her, die ihr da verwendet?
Also meistens, also immer, wir haben so einen DSL-Vertrag mit so einem Internet-Anbieter und dann diese Hardware sind also zu 90 Prozent gespendet. Also wir bekommen Anrufe von Leuten, die uns dann Computer oder Laptops auch spenden.
Kann man da auch, also falls irgendwie einer von seinem neuartigen Rundfunk- und Fangsgerät in sich denkt, aha, mein alten Computer loswerden, nehmt ihr da alles oder muss man da den Niegelnagel neuen Luxusrechner hinschaffen? Oder was wird da gebraucht, was benutzt ihr da?
Also nicht ganz nagelneu, aber nicht auch sehr, sehr alt. Also dass es Internet tauglich ist. Also wir nehmen zum Beispiel Duacore im Moment. Weil wir haben viele, viele Pentum-4, die sehr, sehr langsam sind, die wir auch als Spende bekommen haben. Da haben wir gesagt, okay, jetzt sollen wir einen Minimalstandard geben, dass wir minimal, also wo wir vorhin schon Facebook hatten, ein YouTube-Video soll ich das abspielen können.
Und Facebook sollte auch funktionieren.
Ich versuche mal die Minimalanforderungen zu formulieren. Wenn ich vor einem Rechner sitze und denke, das dauert jetzt echt ganz schön lange, aber wenigstens funktioniert es noch, dann ist es okay. Okay, gut, drunter sollte es nicht sein. Habt ihr denn noch Pläne eigentlich? Also oder erschöpft sich das mit, wir machen diesen Raum, da stecken wir Internet rein, dann stellen wir Hardware rein und dann ist es gut? Oder stellt ihr halt einen Begegnungsort zur Verfügung? Oder gibt es noch Ausbaupläne für die Zukunft?
Also klar, wir haben noch Pläne. Wir wollen alles besser machen. Also wir wollen, dass diese Lähneorte, diese Internet-Cafés so besser funktionieren, weil bis jetzt arbeiten, also es ist von Flüchtlingen selber verwaltet. Und wir haben meistens zwei Flüchtlinge, die sie sich dann wechseln. Also sie arbeiten manchmal zehn Stunden am Tag. Sie machen auf, sie zeigen anderen Flüchtlingen, wie sie ein E-Mail aufmachen können und so weiter. Und sie machen das alles freiwilliger. Und manchmal sind die Flüchtlinge sehr unstabil. Wir haben einen Flüchtling, die wir für drei Monate gebildet haben, der ein Internet-Café verwalten kann und dann plötzlich hat er einen Freund irgendwo und dann ist er weg. Wir wollen langsam diese verantwortliche Entschädigung, also Geldentschädigung, anbieten können. Aber vielleicht nicht viel, aber zumindest, dass wir die Internet-Café stabil halten können. Das ist eine unserer Pläne. Und wir wollen noch Mobilprojekte machen, also Computercourses, mobile Orientierungen für die Flüchtlinge, weil wir haben nicht Internet-Cafés in allen Flüchtlingsheimen in Brandenburg. Also nur Potsdam zum Beispiel hat ca. 14 Flüchtlingsheime. Wir wollen mehr und mehr Freiwillige gewinnen, die auch anderen Flüchtlingen dann beibringen können, auch in Orte, wo es keine Internet-Cafés gibt.
Und sollen das nur Flüchtlinge für Flüchtlinge machen? Oder kann man da auch, wenn man das jetzt als Deutscher irgendwie hört, sagen, ich will da auch helfen? Mir ist das immer nicht ganz klar. Manchmal ist das Hilfsbereitschaft dann auch so, dass man sich so aufdrängt und dann Leuten was wegnimmt. Ist euch das wichtig, dass ihr das quasi unter den Flüchtlingen klärt?
Also es gibt Leute von der Zivilgesellschaft, also Deutsche, die helfen. Also wir arbeiten viel mit Studenten, die helfen. Also aber die Räume, diese Internetcafés, sie werden ausschließlich von den Flüchtlingen selber verwalten. Sie haben den Schlüssel, sie entscheiden, was dort passiert, was sie lernen wollen und Öffnungstreiten und so weiter. Also es ist schon wichtig, dass wir von Anfang an diese Flüchtlinge dann so überlassen, was sie dort machen können. Da kommt diese Vertrauen, diese Partizipation von den Flüchtlingen. Sie sehen, dass sie was Wettvolles machen und es ist sehr wichtig für das Projekt.
Ich muss trotzdem mal fragen, ist das ja eigentlich, weil du gerade beschrieben hast, dass es manchmal sehr instabil ist? Man kann sich das ja auch gut vorstellen. Man ist halt diesen Flüchtlingsheim, hat man zwar diese Aufgabe, aber sobald man da irgendwie raus kann, wird man diese Gelegenheit wahrscheinlich ergreifen. Ist das sehr frustrierend, das so zu machen? Oder wird das zum ganz normalen Teil des Alltags?
Es ist sehr frustrierend, aber es gehört dazu, dass man akzeptieren muss, dass es so passieren kann. Also wir können keine Flüchtlinge so festbienen.
Es hat ja unterschiedliche Aspekte, dieses Frustriertsein, wenn man eben ihnen ein bisschen Geld geben könnte oder dafür sorgt, dass es dann später, wenn sie auf Arbeit suchen, anerkannt wird, wo ich weiß, dass Refugee-Emancipation sich auch um solche Sachen kümmert, dass es nur als Praktikum wenigstens anerkannt wird. Also da lauert sehr, sehr viel, worum man sich kümmern kann, wo ich weiß, dass ihr auch schon ganz viel gemacht habt, was man so im ersten Moment gar nicht sieht. In Marienfelde, dass ihr da jetzt für Kinder einen Raum schafft, damit eben alleinerziehende Mütter ihr Kind mal abgeben können und überhaupt die Möglichkeit haben, ins Internet zu gehen, kommt man im ersten Moment ja auch gar nicht drauf, dass es natürlich nervig ist, wenn ich mit meinem Säugling auf dem Arm im Internet surfen will. Und dann hilft das, wenn ich den mal kurz abgeben kann. Also der Rattenschwanz ist immer sehr groß.
Was sind denn eigentlich die Angebote? Also ich vermute mal, ihr schaut den Leuten jetzt irgendwie nicht über die Schultern, dann schnüffelt sie aus, aber was... Habt ihr Rückmeldung gesagt? Was ist das, wofür wird das Internet am häufigsten verwendet? Also ist es wirklich sozusagen dieses Informieren uns, bilden uns weiter? Oder ist die Unterhaltung auch ein wichtiger Teil? Wisst ihr, wie das verteilt ist?
Ich glaube, Information und Kommunikation ist das, was am meisten benutzt wird. Also wir haben viele Leute, die auch auf Facebook gehen oder E-Mails schreiben. Es gibt auch viele, die rein Entertämen benutzen. Sie gucken dann Videos auf ihre jeweilige Sprache oder Filme und so weiter. Also stellen sie sich vor, sie haben 24 Stunden oder tagsüber haben sie nichts zu tun. Sie gucken viel, viel Sachen auf Internet in ihre jeweilige Sprache.
Eine schöne Anekdote, die ich da erlebt habe, ist, als wir in Hamburg auf dem St. Paulikirchengelände die Flüchtlinge vernetzen konnten und in WLAN bringen konnten, waren sie total begeistert, dass sie jetzt die afrikanische Fußballliga schauen können und mitfiebern können. Das war einfach total schön.
Okay, es gibt also viele Anwendungsmöglichkeiten, für die man sowas braucht. Fehlt jetzt noch was zur Beschreibung des Vereins oder sind wir damit durch? Dann machen wir jetzt eine kleine kurze musikalische Pause, machen dann einen kleinen Ausflug woanders hin und dann geht's zurück. Refugee Emancipation ist für deutsche Zungen echt schwierig auszuprechen. Hat noch einen großen Plan vor, dazu kommen wir dann aber gleich. Die Phrase, die gerne von Asylgegnern benutzt wird, hier schön besungen. Incredible Herren Gedeck hat gleich mehrfach, passt es sozusagen heute her. Einerseits auf Fritzschneu aufgetreten, bei uns signed, der Sendung für Bands ohne Plattenvertrag. Andererseits waren die auch auf dem Chaos Communication Camp. Das war jetzt im August eine riesige Veranstaltung vom Chaos Computer Club, wo Hacker aus aller Welt zusammengekommen sind und da irgendwo mitten in der Pampa gesessen haben. Und das Camp ist tatsächlich nur alle vier Jahre, alle vier oder alle fünf Jahre? Alle wie viel? Alle vier Jahre, aber was es jedes Jahr ist, ist der Chaos Communication Congress. Der ist nämlich immer zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr und dazu gibt es jetzt schon Neuigkeiten.
Ja und zwar ist der Call for Participation drauf. Wer draußen einen Vortrag einreichen möchte, sollte das möglichst schnell tun. Der Call for Participation ist noch bis zum 30. September offen und wir freuen uns über mannigfältige Einreichungen.
Gibt es ein besonderes Thema dieses Jahr? Steht das schon fest?
Das Motto ist mir zumindest noch nicht bekannt.
Das ist ja auch viel zu früh.
Genau, wir wollen ja noch nichts verraten. Es wird aber einen großen Track zu Fails geben, was ich so gehört habe.
Ich finde das tatsächlich ganz spannend. Philosophy ist der Name dafür und da geht es darum, dass die, dass in der Hacker-Szene und generell auch sozusagen wenn jemand was falsch macht, ist es ja häufig so, dass er sagt, du hast was falsch gemacht, du bist ja doof und das Problem ist, dass man sich dann nicht traut, mit seinen eigenen Fehlern an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen, obwohl man eigentlich aus Fehlern gerade beim Programmieren halt sehr sehr sehr viel lernen kann und die Idee hinter diesem philosophy ist, dass man hingeht und sagt, Leute, ich habe das und das falsch gemacht, das ist wirklich schief gegangen, aber ich habe wichtige Dinge gelernt und die dann da präsentiert. Das kann man da machen und wie gesagt, falls ihr einen Vortrag halten wollt und euch eingeladen fühlt, könnt ihr ihn gerne einreichen bis 30. September. Und all das haben wir euch hier in dieser Sendung präsentiert. Und damit herzlich willkommen zur 2. Stunde Chaos Radio im Blohmun. Die Sendung, wo einmal alle 2 Monate der Chaos Computer Club und anverbande Lebensformen das Studieentternamen über digitale Inhalte zu reden. Heute geht es um Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe, wenn Hacker und Flüchtlinge zusammenarbeiten. Und wir haben schon geklärt, warum es total sinnvoll ist, dass man als Flüchtling möglichst schnell Internet hat, nachdem die ganz wichtigen Dinge geklärt sind. Und das geht in zwei Formen. Das eine hat man in der ersten halben Stunde. Es gibt die Freifunker, die sich halt eh damit beschäftigen, Internet an alle Orte zu bringen. Also auch in Flüchtlingsunterkünfte. Und dann gibt es den Verein Refugee Emancipation, richtig ausgesprochen, der sich damit beschäftigt, in Flüchtlingsunterkünften im Prinzip so eine Art Internetcafés zu etablieren, zu betreiben und zu ermöglichen, dass man da ins Netz kommt. Und jetzt, wenn ich das also im Vorfeld richtig verstanden habe, die halbe Stunde soll sich davon handeln, gibt es jetzt das große Zusammenspiel. Eine riesige Mega-Kampagne zu was genau?
Ja, um Refugees Emancipation mit den nötigen finanziellen Mitteln auszustatten. Das, was sie tun, weiter tun zu können, Handlungsspielraum zu geben und das auszubauen.
Und dazu gibt es eine Vorgeschichte, dass ich sozusagen, also weil Refugee... Ich brüchte bitte. Papa Geif, meiner Schulter, der sagen, was man für mich sagt. Refugee Emancipation hat ja in den sozusagen, also funktioniert vor allem in der Heimat. Dann gibt es sozusagen die Hacker-Community, davon auch Teil Freifunker und so weiter. Wie ist das zusammengekommen?
Ja, also im Prinzip waren die Freifunker also nun schon dabei, Flüchtlingsheime und Unterkünfte zu vernetzen. Und eines Tages, wir machen da regelmäßige Treffen in der Sea-Base in Berlin, immer Mittwochs um 20 Uhr. Und eines Tages saß da Philipp und hat erzählt, er hat da Leute vom Refugees Emancipation Projekt getroffen. Und das sei also ganz spannend. Und die würden auch gern in den Heimen WLAN anbieten, weil die Kapazität von so einem Internetcafé natürlich auch begrenzt ist oder die Anzahl der Sitzplätze, man das ein bisschen ausbauen möchte. Und wie wir da denn nun zusammenkommen könnten. Ja, und dann haben wir gesagt, na klar, machen wir das. Und weil ich aber parallel davon gehört habe, dass der Club zu der Zeit Laptops gesammelt hat, sind wir dann als nächstes Chaos Computer Club Berlin aufgeschlagen und haben mit den Leuten unterhalten über das Thema Hardware-Spenden und so weiter. Und die erste Aktion war dann eigentlich, die Hardware-Spenden zu sammeln.
Ja, fast die Hardware-Spenden.
Ich muss mal sehr schnell kurz unterbrechen. Ich habe nämlich, weil wir gerade auch von Fails reden, noch was vergessen vorzustellen an dieser Stelle. Was soll man sagen? Das war gerade Monique Meisel von den Freifunkern. Jetzt Lasse vom Chaos Computer Club, der nochmal genauer erzählt, wie das war.
Das Sammeln der Laptops war das netzpolitische Forum der SPD, die das gemacht haben, die damals den Chaos Computer Club gefragt haben, ob wir sie dabei unterstützen würden, was wir abgelehnt haben, da wir als Chaos Computer Club generell nicht mit Parteien arbeiten. Nach der Ablehnung bin ich hintenrum dann zu ihnen wieder hingerannt und habe gesagt, na gut, wenn ihr die sammelt, dann helfe ich euch beim Einrichten. Und da stellte sich dann, nachdem wir die eingerichtet hatten, halt raus, dass die gar keine Idee hatten, an wen diese 20 Laptops, 30 Laptops jetzt gehen sollen. Wir haben dann mal geguckt, 60 Flüchtlingsunterkünfte in Berlin, 13.000 Flüchtlinge bevor. Wir reden jetzt von Ende letzten Jahres. Also andere Situationen auch hier in Deutschland. Genau November war's. Und in der Fragestellung sozusagen, wem geben wir die denn jetzt? Da hat Monique sich bei mir mal gemeldet und mir von Refugee Emancipation erzählt, was wir sofort super spannend fanden, weil wir in dem Moment es eben nicht an einzelne Flüchtlinge in Privatbesitz geben, sondern an einen Verein, der es wieder vielen zur Verfügung stellt. Und die SPD, dieses Forum war auch sehr offen dafür, dass wir das an Refugee Emancipation geben dürfen, die Laptops. Und so kam man dann eigentlich zusammen. Wir haben damals die Aktion als Einzelperson dann beendet. Und Monique und ich sagten aber, das reicht uns jetzt nicht. Wir möchten Refugee Emancipation gerne noch mehr und weiter unterstützen, als ihnen jetzt einmal 20 Laptops zu geben. Und im Gespräch mit immer und eben kam dann halt immer wieder der Punkt, bei all den Sachen, die sie gerne noch machen würden und wo es drückt und was fehlt, Geld. Das war verschiedenste Themen, aber ganz oft lief es darauf hinaus, um das zu realisieren, braucht man Geld. Sei es jetzt eben, um die Internetadministratoren auf einen Workshop zu schicken, dass die alle mal bei uns im Berliner Club vorbeikommen, das ist einfach für die eine teure Reise. Das haben wir nicht so im Blick, aber Flüchtlinge, selbst wenn du sagst, da sind doch nur 15 Euro, dann können sie mit dem und dem Ticket fahren, das kostet halt alles wieder Geld, die geben eh schon ihre Freizeit und sollen dann noch Geld dafür bezahlen von dem wenigen, was sie haben. Und so kam bei uns eigentlich der Moment, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, dann besorgen wir euch jetzt Geld und planen eine Spendenkampagne zugunsten von Refugee Emancipation. Und mussten dann aber erstmal feststellen, dass wir zu zweit das auch nicht so ganz hinkriegen, weil man weiß ja, wie so eine Kampagne aussehen soll. Man hat da ja ein Bild von und mit Video und was man sich da nicht alles schön ausmalt. Und dann haben wir festgestellt, da sind wir aber ein bisschen weniger für, um das alles zu realisieren.
Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, wie das weiterging, könnte ich noch mal ein bisschen genauer erlauberieren, wofür das Geld gebraucht wird, also was da genau passiert. Außer sozusagen Fahrtkosten für die Internetadministratoren.
Also wie ich dann schon mal gesagt habe, wir wollen zuerst mal ein bisschen Stabilität in den Internetcafés haben. Dann wollen wir die Verantwortlichen für die Internetcafés ein bisschen Geld anbieten, für diese tolle Leistung, die sie dann dort machen. Und dann haben wir immer Computerkursen, Flüchtlingsheime in Internetcafés. Und es gibt Flüchtlinge, die außerhalb kommen. Wenn wir zum Beispiel im Potsdamer Computerkurs, drei Monate Computerkurs anbieten, dann wollen die Flüchtlinge, die in Telto wohnen, die in Brandenburg an der Havel und andere Plätze in Brandenburg, wollen sie auch teilnehmen. Aber das fehlt dann, das Geld für die Fahrkosten. Und wenn wir die Möglichkeit hätten, diese Flüchtlinge Fahrkosten dann zu zahlen, dass sie auch teilnehmen könnten, das wäre toll. Deswegen brauchen wir Geld für Fahrkosten, für diese Cuse, die wir im Internetcafe anbieten. Und dann brauchen wir auch Fahrkosten für die Techniker. Also wir haben immer Computers, die kaputt gehen oder da fehlt ein Maus oder so weiter. Und wir haben so Techniker, die von Internetcafe zu Internetcafe gehen und diese Technik dann zu reparieren. Dann brauchen wir zumindest Fahrkosten. Manchmal auch ein bisschen Honorar für diese Techniker. Und dann, ja, also Fahrkosten sind sehr wichtige Punkte, wofür wir das Geld brauchen. Und dann wir haben auch Büromiete. Dann haben wir auch Leute, die im Büro helfen, die bis jetzt gar nicht bekommen haben. Also wir wollen einfach mal Geld für alle diese Sachen dann.
Die Internetanschlüsse kosten. Es fehlt dann Werkzeug, damit eben, wie immer schön beschrieben hat gerade, die haben ihre eigenen Techniker, die rumreisen, das auf eigene Kosten tun. Aber die brauchen dann auch das entsprechende Werkzeug dazu. Was auch schön zu unserem Titel, so ein bisschen fast Flüchtlinge und Hacker, haben wir es genannt. Es gibt natürlich einen Haufen Flüchtlinge, die Hacker sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob man Jacob Applebaum als Flüchtling bezeichnen würde, aber ich glaube, der möchte gerade auch nicht zurück in sein Land. Und so ein paar andere fallen mir da auch ein, die halt aus der sogenannten ersten Welt kommen, die nehmen halt ein Flugzeug. Viele andere können halt kein Flugzeug hierher nehmen und kommen hier erst mal nicht rein. Aber geflüchtet sind diese Menschen auch. Da fragen wir auch nicht einen Jacob Applebaum, warum er Internet will nebenbei.
Das stimmt. Aber ich höre das jetzt sogar, das sind alles Einzelposten, die jetzt im Einzelnen irgendwie für uns als reiche Erstwälder nicht so dramatisch klingen, aber die sozusagen so zusammen dann schon ein größeres Paket sind.
Wir können ja mal über so ein Reden, also die Refugee Emancipation hat letztes Jahr eine Spendenkampagne probiert durchzuführen und vorbereitet. Und da sind von 6000 Euro, die sie sich gewünscht haben für ein Jahr, ich glaube es waren 50 Euro zusammen bekommen.
Und das war dann genau auch der Grund, warum wir gesagt haben, da können wir vielleicht ein bisschen unter die Arme greifen, eine Kampagne etwas professioneller mit unseren Erfahrungen zu unterstützen, unsere Kontakte zu nutzen. Richtig und einfach auch noch weitere Organisationen jetzt im nächsten Schritt dahinter zu versammeln, die einfach dort unterstützen auf den verschiedensten Ebenen. Aber im ersten Schritt geht es tatsächlich um Geld. Und diese 6000 Euro am Anfang waren ja recht bescheiden, da ging es dann auch nicht um ein ganzes Jahr, da ging es dann nur mal drei Monate Fahrradkosten für einen Lehrer. Wenn wir das jetzt alles überschlagen, kommen wir da auf deutliche Summen. Das Ziel wäre schon, mit einer recht großen Summe dieses Projekt für mindestens ein Jahr im Voraus entsprechend auszustatten, die sowohl die bestehenden Heime, also die Internetcafés in den Heimen, weiter betreiben zu können, als auch, eben hatte gesagt, zwei neue pro Jahr wären realistisch eben auch auszustatten. Wenn man diese ganzen Fahrtkosten mal überschlägt, dann sammelt sich das da ganz schön. Also da kommen wirklich Summen zusammen, da reden wir von mehreren Zehntausend Euro.
Und es geht ein Stück weit aus meiner Sicht zumindest auch um Vertrauen. Refugee Emancipation hat jetzt wirklich in 14 Jahren unbeobachtet von allen und an allen vorbei mal eben acht Internetcafés in Flüchtlingsunterkünften bereitgestellt aus eigener Tasche sozusagen mit ein bisschen Spenden, mit ein bisschen Unterstützung von Hackern. Und zumindest von meiner Seite ist das volle Vertrauen da. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal sehen, was passiert, wenn man Refugee Emancipation, die entsprechenden Mittel zur Verfügung stellt, um das mal in groß auszurollen. Weil, dass sie es können, haben sie halt schon bewiesen. Schon lange.
Also quasi nach Freilacht im Auto, lassen sie sich mal mit Geld bewerfen, gucken, was dann passiert.
Nein, das sind schon ganz konkrete Bedarfe, was immer eben auch sagt. Das wäre halt schön, das ist eben auch in großer Selbstausbeutung natürlich passiert, da eben Tier und da einfach auch Aufwandsentschädigungen zahlen zu können. Da redet man nicht pro Person, sicherlich nicht über hohe Summen, aber ja, das läppert sich halt alles ganz schön zusammen. Und Reisen, ich weiß nicht, wann habt ihr euch das letzte Mal eine Umweltkarte gekauft? Oder eine Berlin-Brandenburg-Umweltkarte, ein Jahr lang? Das kostet schon ein bisschen was.
Jetzt habt ihr gesagt, ihr habt es irgendwie zu zweit versucht, hat nicht ganz geklappt. Wer kommt jetzt noch dazu?
Ja, wir haben dann einen Plan gemacht eigentlich und sind erstmal mit dem Thema hausieren gegangen. Ich hab dann auf der Hey10 einen Vortrag dazu gehalten, dass ich vorhätte, zum Campin, was ja anstand, das Chaos Communication Camp, diese Spendenkampagne mit Monique und Freifunk zusammenzumachen. Das gleiche habe ich auf dem hedonistischen Weltkongress getan, beim CCC in Hamburg. Beim Netzpolitischen Abend haben wir uns mit Annabie Seddi und Fiona noch mal hingestellt und das Projekt erklärt. Und eigentlich kam so jedes Mal, wenn man darüber geredet hat, davon erzählt hat, immer noch mal ein, zwei Leute dazu. Es wird so eine Kerntruppe zum Schluss von 18, 19 Leuten waren, mit ganz unterschiedlichen Hintergründen, größtenteils schon aus dem CCC und Freifunkumfeld, was auch zum Schluss ja dazu geführt hat, dass es, nachdem wir uns irgendwann gesagt haben, so richtig Einzelpersonen sind wir jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr, weil wir haben hier gerade die volle Kraft von Freifunk und dem Förderverein und dem CCC am Rande zusammen. Dann war es halt ein kurzer Schritt, unsere Vorstände jeweils zu fragen, machen wir das als diese Organisation? Und die waren natürlich toll, wie sie sind, auch gleich Feuer und Flamme und haben uns unterstützt.
Ich hab mich selbst überzeugt.
Genau, Monique hat sich selbst überzeugt. Ich bin offiziell den Weg über unsere Vorstände gegangen und hab auch gleich mal bei den Sprechern angefragt, wobei da kam eigentlich gar kein richtiges Ja, da kam nur ein Machen, wie kann ich helfen? Und ja, war sehr beeindruckend und sehr schön zu sehen. Und so kam diese bunte Truppe jetzt zusammen und inzwischen eben dann offiziell unter dem Dach des Chaos Computer Clubs, des Fördervereins Freien Netzwerke und von Freifunk.
Jetzt ist es immer die eine Sache sozusagen, so eine Kampagne loszutreten, dann das Geld einzusammeln. Da ist es meistens so, dass alle Energie sich darauf zuspitzt. Und wenn es dann geklappt hat, dann ist die Luft raus. Gibt es schon so einen Plan für danach, was dann passiert, falls es klappen sollte? Also ich meine, wo man wahrscheinlich ausgehen kann, allein aus dem eigenen Umfeld?
Das Gute ist, wir dürfen ja umfallen und die Luft darf erstmal kurz raus sein, weil Refugee Emancipation bekommt ja das Geld und nicht wir. Wir sind wirklich nur Unterstützer. Das ist uns auch immer wichtig, das ganz doll zu trennen. Und wir sind nicht Refugee Emancipation, wir sind die Unterstützer. Und machen diese Kampagne zugunsten von Refugee Emancipation. Trotz alledem wollen wir nicht umfallen, sondern mehrere Leute haben schon angekündigt, dass sie auch über diese Kampagne hinaus weiter Refugee Emancipation unterstützen möchten, weiter mit ihnen arbeiten möchten.
Es gibt tatsächlich schon konkretere Pläne, dann auch für eine zweite Phase, denn um nochmal das Thema Hardware sammeln besser aufzurollen, das ist halt eine logistische Aufgabe. Die Heime sind in Brandenburg, da kann ich jetzt den Berliner nicht sagen, ja fahrt mal dahin und liefert das mal direkt dort ab. Das ist eine kleine logistische Herausforderung, die vielleicht durch Sammelstellen irgendwie zu lösen geht und zu organisieren geht. Und natürlich geht es dann auch weiter in der dritten Phase eben diese Computer Kurse zu unterstützen. Da haben sich auch schon Gruppen gefunden, die gesagt haben, Mensch, Geld ist ja das eine, aber da kann man doch auch ganz viel mit Zeit machen und so. Und dann sag ich, na klar kann man das, super. Genau und dann wird es dann in der zweiten, dritten Phase dann eben auch Workshops geben von den Freifunkern, die dann auch Flüchtlinge an der Stelle ermächtigen, selbst auch diese Infrastruktur zu warten oder aufzustellen, sich selbst zu helfen. Das soll immer das Ziel sein, Empowerment, also Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe.
Falls man sich das alles gehört und denkt, okay, das klingt ja alles ganz gut, aber wo Internetadresse, irgendwas?
support.refugeesemancipation.com Wie, das Schreibmuster selber rausfinden?
Vielleicht schreibt es ja auch jemand im Internet auf, der mitgehört hat. Es gibt ja da so Leute, die sich zur Sendung immer hinsetzen und alles feinsäublich mitschreiben unter Show Notes.
Und ich denke, wenn man dem CCC oder Freifunk oder dem Förderverein in den üblichen sozialen Medien selbst Facebook folgt, dann wird man das die nächsten Tage auch noch öfter mal mitbekommen.
Ganz wichtig ist vielleicht noch zu erwähnen, dass man sich zurzeit auf dieser Webseite für ein Newsletter registrieren kann und der große Start der Spendenkampagne spitzt sich also zu. Am 1. Oktober wird das lanciert und ab da können dann alle fleißig spenden auf diese Kampagne.
So, so. Wir sind sehr gespannt, was daraus wird. Ist dann der Werbeblock hiermit beendet? Gut, wir haben nachher noch so ein Thema, was es für Probleme mit Deutschland gibt, wenn man da Internet hinbringen will, also mit den Strukturen. Ich würde aber gerne nochmal vorher, weil wir gerade in dem Modus sind, nochmal sagen, es gibt ja auch noch wahrscheinlich andere Projekte, die sich mit dem Thema Digitales und Flüchtlinge beschäftigen. Zum Beispiel soll es einen Refugee Hackathon geben. Wer weiß von euch da genaueres?
Dazu kann ich etwas sagen. Und zwar soll am 24. bis 26. Oktober in Berlin der Refugees Hackathon stattfinden. Ziel ist es, hier haben sich ja unheimlich viele Gruppen gebildet. Also von Web-Plattformen über Facebook organisieren sich Helfer und Flüchtlinge, über Apps. Es gibt da diverse Apps, teilweise nur mit leicht verschobenem Fokus. Und ein bisschen ist es so, es läuft noch recht unkoordiniert. Jeder findet so ein bisschen das Rad neu, ganz viele gute Ideen. Und das Ziel dieses Hackathons ist es halt, die Leute zusammenzubringen, zu schauen, wo sind wir schon ganz nah beieinander. Auf der anderen Seite, was fehlt noch, sich da kennenzulernen und besser zu vernetzen, sich auch gegenseitig Input zu geben und am Ende natürlich dann auch am Wochenende da weitere Features zu schrauben und das Ganze zu hacken. Unter refugeehackathon.de kann man sich die Infos alle holen. Da sieht man auch schon eine Liste der zurzeit aktiven Gruppen dort. Aber da sind noch, also wer noch was weiß, wer da noch fehlt, dann auf jeden Fall dahin schicken.
Die Jugend ist auch schon am Start. Halt!
Ich wollte nur von wegen refugeehackathon.de. Was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass sie da mittlerweile, das ist ja in Berlin, sollte man vielleicht auch mal dazu sagen, in Berlin der hackathon, das sich mittlerweile also in Deutschlandweit irgendwie so auch abzeichnet, dass andere Leute auch was dazu machen. Also falls ihr nicht aus Berlin kommt, vielleicht ist in eurer Gegend da auch irgendwie was am Start. So, die Jugend?
Die Jugend ist auch am Start. Jugendhack wird als einen großen Track beim diesjährigen Jugendhack in Berlin Refugees haben und sich auch dort mit dem Thema befassen, gucken, was kann man da programmiertechnisch sozusagen machen. Das Ganze findet in Berlin vom 16. bis 18. Oktober statt. Ich hab gehört, es gibt noch ein paar letzte freie Plätze.
Für Hackerinnen vor allem.
Prima, die werden bevorzugt. Ansonsten mal neben Internet und weil wir vorhin ja auch sagten, es gibt auch durchaus andere Sachen in Berlin, wo es noch dran mangelt. Und das gilt dann eigentlich für alle Bundesländer, denke ich. Eigentlich hat jedes Bundesland ein Flüchtlingsrat, wenn nicht sogar Städte teilweise. Und der Flüchtlingsrat Berlin, den man mit Google ganz leicht findet, hat eine wunderbare Linksammlung zu so ziemlich allen lokalen Initiativen, wo man sich beteiligen kann. Da kann man wirklich, muss man noch nicht mal seinen Stadtteil zuverlassen in der Regel, weil vor der eigenen Haustür gibt es schon eine Gruppe, die sich kümmert. Und alle freuen sich über Leute, die helfen im Moment, weil es wird überall nach Unterstützung gesucht. Ich hab leider immer wieder jetzt auch Leute erlebt, die seit zwei Monaten kaum ihrem eigenen Job nachgehen, weil sie sich da voll dieser Sache widmen. Und je mehr Leute mitmachen, je mehr Schultern das Ganze tragen, umso leichter wird es für alle.
Okay, dann gibt es also genug Gelegenheit, um auch zu helfen. Wir wollen jetzt noch mal zurückkommen zu dem, womit wir auch angefangen haben, nämlich Internet in Flüchtlingsunterkünfte bringen. Und es wäre ja zu einfach, Probleme, die es dabei gibt. Welche sind das? Also ich meine jetzt abgesehen davon, dass man einen Internetanschluss braucht und technische Geräte dieses Internet sozusagen unter bis zu 2000 Leuten verteilen, gibt es anscheinend noch institutionelle Probleme oder formale Probleme oder was auch immer?
Also es fängt meistens mit dem Internetanschluss selber an, dass man den gar nicht hat. Das wäre ja zu einfach, wenn man irgendwie lokal einen VDSL-Anschluss bestellen könnte. Also viele dieser Unterkünfte sind far out. Da kann man dann froh sein, wenn man da 16 MBit ADSL hinkriegt. Und dann wohnen da aber viele Leute. Also es fängt damit an, dass man überhaupt irgendeine Art von Bandbreite herbekommt und die zur Verfügung stellen kann. Damit fängt es schon mal an.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja ein Problem, das kennen alle Brandenbogen. Gibt es da irgendwie einen Lösungsansatz für? Weil das ist halt in Deutschland so eine Art Naturgewalt. Wir haben halt einfach nicht überall Internet.
Das ist natürlich das eine. Klar, da kann man dann versuchen, mit Richtfunksstrecken irgendwas hinzubringen. Aber es gibt auch noch andere Probleme. Solche Unterkünfte sind manchmal auch einfach gegen den Willen der Betreiber errichtet worden. Also gerade hier in Berlin wurden quasi Sporthallen vom Deutschen Sportbund beschlagnahmt. Also nicht durch den Sportbund, aber vom Sportbund. Und die Bereitschaft, da jetzt irgendwie die Schränke aufzumachen und zu sagen, hier könnt ihr mal was anschließen, die ist da relativ gering. Weil die Leute sehen, die nehmen uns jetzt hier was weg.
Beziehungsweise, ja genau, dann kommt eben dieses Argument, was wir anfänglich schon mal entkräftet haben. Das ist doch gar nicht so entscheidend. Also gibt es nicht Wichtigeres so als das. Das geht dann aber auch weiter. Diese Betreiber-Organisationen sind ja sehr, sehr unterschiedlich. Einige sind sowieso schon aus Hilfsorganisationen, wie die Diakonie oder die AWO oder so. Aber es gibt auch private Betreiber, wo man damit ganz oder quasi Wohnungsbaugesellschaften eigentlich auch, die eine ganz andere Verwaltungsstruktur haben, mit der man sich dann rumplagen muss, wenn man da nun hinkommt und sagt, wir würden hier gerne helfen und unterstützen. Des Weiteren ist sicherlich technisches Unwissen ein Problem. Und last not least ist die Störerhaftung. Unsere alte Bekannte im Freifunkkontext, eins der größten Hindernisse. Es wirkt sich aus wie eine Kontaktsperre für die Flüchtlinge, weil die Betreiber eben sagen, wir möchten hier nicht in dieser Haftung sein.
Also Leute, die jetzt sozusagen ganz, ganz, ganz super aufmerksam das Chaosradio hören, die wissen möglicherweise, worum es geht. Alle anderen möchte ich auch bis nach den Nachrichten vertrösten und sozusagen das so schon mal andeuten. Es gibt eine juristisch-gesetzliche, ja ein Ding, was es verhindern kann, dass man dieses, was man eigentlich total, also eigentlich total gut. Hey, wir machen Internet für euch. Und dann gibt es sowas wie, ja, aber vielleicht bist du dann dran, wenn jemand was Böses tut. Und dann sagen viele Leute so, ha, nee, dann wollen wir das doch lieber nicht. Ich fasse es genau aus, das kennen wir gleich. Jetzt gibt es noch einen Musikwunsch, der mitgebracht wurde. Ja, bitte.
Ich wollte noch anmerken, die Anna Biselli von netzpolitik.org hat doch einen sehr schönen Artikel drüber geschrieben.
Ja, aber darüber sprechen wir doch gleich.
Ah, ich war jetzt nicht bei Störerhaftung, aber gut.
Worüber jetzt? Jetzt bin ich total durcheinander. Worüber denn? Hat sie über Slime einen Artikel geschrieben? Auch nicht. Gut, dann hören wir jetzt erst Slime und Goldene Turme und danach gibt's Nachrichten und danach klären wir den ganzen Rest.
Na, da geben wir doch mal unseren Senf dazu.
Dezember. Fritz Nachrichten mit Emily Ulbricht.
Die Bundesländer sollen vom Bund mehr Geld zur Bewältigung der Flüchtlingskrise erhalten. Die Regierung will sich monatlich mit 670 Euro pro Flüchtling an den Kosten beteiligen, sagte Bundeskanzlerin Merkel am Abend nach dem Treffen mit dem Ministerpräsidenten im Kanzleramt. Außerdem sollen 500 Millionen Euro für den sozialen Wohnungsbau und weitere 350 Millionen für die Betreuung unbegleiteter minderjähriger Flüchtlinge bereitgestellt werden. Ungarn schottet sich in der Flüchtlingskrise weiter ab. Armee und Polizei bauen derzeit Zäune an den Grenzen zu Slowenien, Kroatien und Rumänien. Das berichtete die staatliche ungarische Nachrichtenagentur MIT. Außerdem hat die ungarische Regierung angekündigt, die Ausgaben für den Bau von Grenzzeugen zu verdoppeln. Die Übergänge zu Serbien sind bereits abgeriegelt. In Saudi-Arabien hat sich eines der größten Unglücke der vergangenen Jahre während der islamischen Pilgerfahrt Hatsch ereignet. Bei einer Massenpanik in der Nähe von Mekka sind mehr als 700 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Weitere 800 Menschen wurden verletzt. Der saudische König Saiman versprach eine schnelle Aufklärung der Unglücksursache. Außerdem wolle er die bisherigen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen während der Pilgerfahrt prüfen lassen. Mehrere Zeitungen berichten, dass Porsche-Chef Müller neuer Vorstandsvorsitzender beim VW-Konzern wird. Außerdem sollen weitere Manager ihre Posten räumen. VW-Chef Winterkorn war gestern zurückgetreten. Hintergrund ist, dass VW bei den Abgaswerten von Dieselautos getrickst hat. Heute bestätigte der Autokonzern, dass auch Fahrzeuge in Europa betroffen sind. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, die liegen in Berlin-Marzahn bei 11 Grad, in Reinickendorf sind es 14 Grad, in Forsten 10 Grad, in Zieser 11 und in Brandenburg an der Havel und Eberswalde jeweils 12 Grad. In der Nacht wird es locker bewölkt, bleibt aber meistens trocken. Erst morgens kann es etwas regnen bei Tiefstwerten bis zu 7 Grad. Morgen müsst ihr dann mit ein paar Meerwolken und teilweise auch Regen in Berlin und Brandenburg rechnen. Die Temperaturen sind ähnlich wie heute, 16 bis 19 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Neukölln, die Flughafenstraße ist zwischen Fontanestraße und Hermannstraße nach einem Unfall gesperrt und der Tiergattentunnel ist ebenfalls gesperrt bis 5 Uhr früh. Grund sind Wartungsarbeiten. Nach Brandenburg auf der A9 leibt sich Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Niemäck und Brück gab es einen Unfall auf der linken Spur. Die Unfallstelle ist noch nicht gesichert. Hier also bitte vorsichtig fahren. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt oder diesen Sound Dann hört doch mal Urban Tunes. Den Fritz Soundgarden mit Claudia Kameed. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Die letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio in Blue Moon ist angebrochen. Wir sprechen heute über Flüchtlinge und Hackerhilfe zur Selbsthilfe und zu Gast sind. Monique Meisel von den Freifunkern. Hallo und guten Abend. Ima Tchenko von Refugee Emancipation. Hallo. Lasse vom Chaos Computer Club. Und Elektra vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir haben schon 90 Minuten hinter uns. Und die alle noch mal zusammenzufassen, würde den Rahmen der Verbleibenden seine Zeit sprengen. Deswegen nur ganz kurz, es ist wichtig, dass Flüchtlinge Internet haben. Auf wie das passieren kann, haben wir so kurz geklärt. Es gibt verschiedene Ansätze und wir wollen den einen jetzt noch mal vertiefen. Das ist nämlich der, dass man einfach in die Flüchtlingsunterkünfte geht und da Internet hinwirft. Wie man das dann genau benutzt, haben wir im Rahmen der Sendung schon erklärt. Aber es gibt da Probleme. Also es gibt nicht nur das technische Problem, dass man irgendwie die Technik hinschaffen muss und dass man irgendwie alles organisieren muss, sondern es gibt, wie soll man das sagen, übergeordnete Probleme, die bürokratischer, formaler oder juristischer Natur sein könnte. Und da ist ein Problem, das man haben kann, die Störerhaftung. Frau Meilde.
Also die Störerhaftung ist erst mal kein Gesetz, sondern es ist eigentlich lediglich eine Rechtsunsicherheit. Das kam zustande durch einen BGH-Uteil, was mal gefällt wurde in Bezug auf offenes WLAN, was sozusagen sagte, dass man für das, was dritte in einem ungesicherten WLAN tun oder ungesichertem Internetzugang tun könnte, verantwortlich gemacht werden könnte, sprich also eben auch haftet.
Da muss ich reingrätschen an der Stelle. Störerhaftung ist ein juristisches Konzept im Zivilrecht. Das geht dabei nicht nur ums Internet. Wenn eine Sache, die dir gehört, von jemand anderem benutzt wird, etwas zu tun, was mich stört, dann kannst du da unter bestimmten Bedingungen dafür in Haftung genommen werden. Und es ist tatsächlich so ausgelegt worden in den vergangenen Jahren. Also wir sehen, es ist auf dem Rückzug, aber dass Menschen dafür verantwortlich gemacht wurden, dass andere Leute ihren Internetzugang benutzt haben und sich zum Beispiel irgendwas von Madonna runtergeladen und hochgeladen haben über eines der Filesharing-Protokolle. Oder irgendwas anderes Banales.
Und um das nochmal zu konkretisieren, ursprünglich kommt das aus sowas wie du musst ein AKW sichern. Daher kommt das, da macht das auch Sinn. Gegen den Zugriff Dritter unter anderem.
Oder dein Gartenteich. Dein Gartenteich, da fällt ein Kind rein. Weil du den nicht gesichert hast, dann kann man dich damit belangen.
Genau, und dann wurde das eben von findigen Anwälten auf dieses WLAN eben auch angewandt. Und das WLAN oder das Internet wird dort als Gefahrenzone hingestellt. Was natürlich total lächerlich ist, denn uns einbewusst, dass das lediglich ein Kommunikationsmedium ist.
Genau, und du hast von Problemen gesprochen.
Wie haben wir eine Lösung dafür? Um das konkret mal deutlich zu machen, ich stelle mich jetzt als ehrenamtlicher Helfer und sage, ich richte euch einen Internetanschluss ein und damit es alles schnell geht, mache ich das einfach auf meinen Namen und dann surfen da, was war es im Teilfall, 2000 Leute über diesen Internetanschluss. Und wenn da einer Unsinn baut, was möglicherweise passieren kann, wenn 2000 Leute auf einem Platz sind, dann bist du als Anschlussinhaber möglicherweise in der juristischen Haftung drin. Und dann überlegt man sich das vielleicht irgendwie dreimal oder viermal, ob man das wirklich machen will, also ob man garantieren will, dass ganz viele Leute irgendwie alle keinen Unsinn brauchen. Wie ist die Lösung dafür, um sozusagen dem zu entgehen?
Gibt es mehrere Lösungen dafür. Wir haben quasi dieses Problem mit der Störerhaftung nur in Deutschland, was auch ein Grund dafür ist, dass Deutschland im internationalen Vergleich sehr weit hinterherhinkt, irgendwie was öffentliche Internetzugänge anbelangt. Da haben wir uns selber ein Eigentor geschossen und leider schießen wir immer weiter solche Eigentore. Und das wird auch immer so weitergehen, wenn wir nicht irgendwie aufstehen und dagegen was machen.
Ja, genau. Und die Lösungen sehen vielfältig aus. Wie gesagt, das ist eine Rechtsunsicherheit. Da muss das Recht eben ausgelegt werden. Das heißt, wir haben einmal den juristischen Weg bestritten, in zwei Beispielfällen haben wir dann die vermeintlichen, ja, gegen, also theoretisch steht man ja erstmal dann selber sozusagen, wenn man so, also die Konsequenzen kriegt eine Abmahnung, ja. Dann hab ich erstmal Angst und denke, oh Gott, oh Gott, was wir gemacht haben, ist immer gesagt, nein, wir zahlen nicht, wir unterlassen nicht bei so einer Abmahnung für Filesharing beispielsweise. Und dann ging es eben weiter, dass einfach mal gar nichts passiert ist. Und weil immer nie was passiert ist und komischerweise die Leute nur Angst gemacht wurde, aber am Ende niemand verklagt wurde von den Freifunkern, haben wir gesagt, Moment mal, dann drehen wir jetzt den Spieß um, Verteidigung nach vorne und haben Feststellungsklagen angestrengt, die wir im ersten Fall haben die... Aha, okay, eine Feststellungsklage bedeutet in dem Fall, ich möchte feststellen lassen, dass was du mir vorwürfst, du mir nicht vorwerfen darfst. Ist eine sogenannte negative Feststellungsklage. Ich lasse also negativ feststellen, um es mal ganz ausführlich zu machen. Da ist also Folgendes passiert, dass eine dafür sehr berühmte Kanzlei die Ansprüche für ihre Mandanten hat fallen lassen und auch in allen anderen Fällen gegen Freifunker, die da anhängig waren. Und im zweiten Fall haben wir tatsächlich am Landgericht Berlin einen gewonnen. Ein positives Urteil, was allerdings in dem Fall weniger auf die Störerhaftung konkret eingegangen ist, sondern hier war die erste Verteidigungslinie unseres Klägers zu sagen, ich zweifle an, dass die IP-Adressermittlung korrekt war. Das heißt, wir finden dann immer raus, wem gehört dieser Anschluss, zu der diese IP gehört und so weiter. Und wir wissen halt, dass sie in ungefähr 30 Prozent der Fälle inkorrekt ist. Und tatsächlich haben auch die Richter das so gesehen, dass sie gesagt haben, das ist hier gar nicht hinreichend dargelegt, dieses Verfahren der IP-Adressermittlung. Und somit haben wir gewonnen. Und Punkt. Eine Möglichkeit.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, aber wenn das... Ich wollte gerade sagen, eine sehr aufwändige. Das heißt, jetzt im konkreten Fall, wir wollen jetzt jetzt in 50-Sonderkünften, will man sich da wahrscheinlich nicht drauf verlassen.
Genau, weil ja auch, wir wollen ja auch, dass Menschen, die sich jetzt nicht so auskennen und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Angst haben, trotzdem Freifunk machen, haben wir schon vor längerer Zeit mit den sogenannten Freedom-Fighter-Boxes gezeigt, dass man mittels sogenannten VPN-Tunneln den Internet-Traffic umleiten kann. Und der wird umgeleitet entweder ins Ausland, wo es keine Störerhaftung gibt, oder zuletzt in letzter Zeit eigentlich auch zu deutschen Providern, die eben unter das sogenannte Provider-Privileg fallen, was dazu führt, dass man nicht in der Haftung ist, sonst hätte ja die Telekom auch ständig Probleme mit ihren Hotspots.
Und sozusagen dann, also in so einer Flüsschensunterkunft stellt ihr einfach so ein Ding hin und dann ist das sozusagen gegessen?
Genau, in dem Freifunk. Wir flächen ja die Router mit einer alternativen Firmware und in dieser Firmware trägt man dann diesen VPN-Tunnel ein, es stellt noch ein, wie viel Bandbreite man im Zweifel teilen möchte. Und genau, und dann hat man da im Prinzip schon den Schutz.
Wobei man jetzt sagen muss, das ist die Freifunk-Lösung. Refugee-Emancipation hat das anders gemacht.
Wir müssen kurz das Mikrofon wechseln.
Wir haben zu wenig Mikrofone für diese vielen Gäste. Ja, wir haben das anders gemacht mit dieser Internet-Räume. Also wir geben nicht nur Internet, aber wir haben dann diese DSL in diese Internet-Cafés. Und dann haben die Flüchtlinge dann Internetzugang mit dieser DSL-Anschlüsse.
Die Anschlüsse laufen auf Refugee-Emancipation. Also sie halten sozusagen ihren Kopf für die anderen Flüchtlinge hin, sprechen ihnen das Vertrauen aus, zu sagen, ok, ihr dürft alle über unseren Anschluss surfen. Und wir jetzt eben drüber geredet haben, was da theoretisch schiefgehen kann. Wie viele Fälle hattet ihr, wo es deswegen Ärger gab?
Also ich kenne einen Fall, wo wir illegal downloaden, also einen Brief bekommen haben. Also vor 14 Jahren kenne ich nur einen Fall. Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch mehr Fälle gibt. Also wir haben dann allgemein einen Vertrag mit der Heimbetreiber. Das heißt, wir haben in Anschluss die Hardways. Und was alles in diese Räume passiert ist, trägt Refugees-Emancipation die Verantwortung. Dann haben die Heimbetreiber gar nicht. Und von unserer Erfahrung haben wir selten Probleme mit solchen Fällen gehabt.
Habt ihr andere Probleme oder mit Dingen zu kämpfen, wo man denkt, okay, damit habe ich jetzt aber gar nicht gerechnet?
Allgemein begegnen wir sehr oft diese allgemeine Angst von den Heimbetreibern. Also wenn sie von einem selbst organisierten Flüchtlingsprojekt hören, dann haben sie diese Angst, wenn Flüchtlinge sich dann organisieren und über Internet, vielleicht könnte sie politisch werden. Und dann allgemein, sie wollen keine zweite Stimme haben. Der Heimbetreiber oder die Heimleiter sagt, wie es dort läuft, und wollen selten keine andere Meinung haben.
Ich verstehe das richtig. Die Heimbetreiber haben davor Angst, dass die Leute, für die sie das Heim betreiben, sich über das Internet so organisieren, dass sie sozusagen ein Gewicht bekommen.
Also dass die Flüchtlinge, also die Heimleiter, sie haben Angst, dass die Flüchtlinge sie organisieren können und dann politisch werden. Also dass sie ihre Meinung sagen können, wie wir dann leben, die Zustände sind nicht in Ordnung und so weiter. Dass sie sich dann besser auskennen. Also sie haben das Problem, also begegnen wir sehr oft diese allgemeinen Angst.
Aber wie äußert sich das? Ich kann mir ja kaum vorstellen, dass ein Heimleiter oder ein Heimbetreiber öffentlich sagt, ich will nicht, dass ihr euch organisiert.
Sie sagen das nicht, da sie Angst haben. Aber wir wissen das. Sie sagen, sie haben immer diese Ausrede, wir haben keine Räume. Wir haben andere Prioritäten. Und wer bezahlt das? Wir haben Angst für illegal Downloads und so weiter. Wenn wir dann sagen, alles was dort passiert, tragen wir die Verantwortung, dann sagen wir, ach nee, dann haben wir keine Räume. Wenn wir Räume hätten, aber wir sagen immer, Internet ist kein Luxus oder diese Räume, diese Internet-Cafés sind kein Luxus, es ist eine Notwendigkeit für die Flüchtlinge.
Also Anna Biselli von netzpolitik.org hat auch Refugee Emancipation kennengelernt im Zuge des letzten Jahres und hat sich dann mal ganz allgemein mit diesem Thema bundesweit befasst. Und genau die Dinge, die Refugee Emancipation im Kleinen zu hören bekommen hat, hat sie dann eigentlich bundesweit zu hören gekriegt. Das sind immer die gleichen Sachen. Erstmal, ja, die haben doch alle Smartphones. Dass sie darüber vielleicht keinen Datenvertrag haben, das haben wir schon drüber geredet. Die können ja öffentliche Zugänge nutzen. Da ist ein McDonalds in 5 Kilometer Entfernung. Da darf man eine halbe Stunde umsonst surfen. Das reicht doch. Und dann eben als dritter Punkt, den wir jetzt am ausführlichsten schon behandelt haben, genau diese rechtlichen Bedenken. Die surfen doch alle auf Al-Qaeda-Seiten und dann sind wir schuld. Kein Witz, also wirklich, das wird sehr, sehr gerne. IS ist jetzt gerade aktuell, früher war es Al-Qaeda. Davor wird es irgendeine andere Sau, die sie gerade durchs Dorf jagen gewesen sein, die dann schuld ist und alle Flüchtlinge machen ja nichts anderes. Dass sie gerade genau vor diesen Leuten flüchten, wird dann gern vergessen.
Wir haben genau diese gleichen Erfahrungen auch gemacht, mit dieser Verzögerungstaktik, wie eben auch Refugees Emancipation. Wenn wir mit diesen Betreibern reden, dann heißt es, der Internetanschluss ist zu schmalbandig, dann sagen wir gut, dann versorgen wir von außen. Dann sagen die, ja, aber wie ist denn mit der Haftung das? Dann sagen wir, dafür haben wir eine Lösung. Machen sie sich keine Sorgen, wir stehen in der Haftung im Zweifel. Und so weiter und so weiter. Es ist wirklich immer das Gleiche. Das ist wirklich traurig.
Der eigentliche Skandal ist, dass du es mit den einzelnen Haiben klären musst. Als wir dann geguckt haben, wie ist denn die gesetzliche Regelung und Anna sich gekümmert hat und wir haben damals viel geredet, stellte sich halt raus, es gibt einfach gar keine gesetzliche Regelung. Erst heißt es, es ist Ländersache. Die Länder sagen dann, je nachdem, wie das Land drauf ist, ja, das ist aber Sache der Gemeinde oder Kommune. Die Gemeinde sagt, es ist Sache des Heims. Und so wird sich der Schwarze Peter dann schön zugeschoben. Und genau für Freifunk ist es dann zum Beispiel auch ein Problem, mal zu einer generellen Lösung für ein ganzes Bundesland zu kommen, weil du auf einmal mit jeder Heimleitung einzeln reden musst.
Also ich meine, meine persönliche Einschätzung ist, dass hinter solchen Vorbehalten stecken häufig Ausreden. Und ich meine, es ist einfach nicht zu leugnen. Legen wir doch die Fakten klar auf den Tisch. Es gibt in Deutschland, so wie in vielen anderen Staaten auch oder wahrscheinlich überall auf der Welt, Alltagsrassismus. Den gibt es einfach. Es gibt ein Wir-Gefühl. Und Menschen, die anders sind, denen begegnet man mit Xenophobie. Die sind irgendwie anders, die wollen irgendwas von uns, die sind irgendwie komisch. Die wollen uns irgendwas wegnehmen. Ich meine, wir reden doch hier vor dem Hintergrund der ganzen politischen Diskussionen, die wir alle schon mitbekommen haben. Wir sehen das doch. Ich kann wirklich nur jedem empfehlen, mal in der Wikipedia den Alltagsrassismus nachzuschlagen. Und dass Leute dann halt an ihre Grenzen, ihrer Toleranz kommen, die immer so gerne zitiert werden und dann irgendwelche Dinge vorschützen, ist halt einfach auch ein gesellschaftliches Problem, was wir haben. Und das können wir allein mit Technik nicht erschlagen.
Oder zumindest nur mit äußerst viel Aufwand, der gar nicht nötig wäre, wenn man diese technischen Fixes da eben nicht bräuchte.
Also finde ich das nicht nur eine spannende Diskussion, die man nochmal führen könnte, wenn ich 15 Stunden vor Sender Schluss wäre. Ob das wirklich sozusagen der einzige Grund ist, weil ich mir tatsächlich, also ich habe manchmal den Verdacht, dass so, also gerade wenn so ich bin der Betreiber einer öffentlichen Einrichtung, dass es dann auch das hätt ich manchmal einfach ums Geld geht oder um die Angst vor juristischem Ärger.
Warum ist im Moment, wo wir jetzt diese Krise auch hier in Deutschland hatten, warum ist nicht das THW, das Rote Kreuz nach vorne gesprungen und hat gesagt, ja wir helfen, offiziell habe ich da noch gar nichts zugehört. Ich habe an verschiedenen Stellen mal nachgefragt. Es will keiner das in seinem Budget haben. Die sind doch selber alle schon landunter. Das ist ja nicht mehr böse, aber die wissen einfach auch, wenn wir jetzt die ersten sind, die uns aus der Deckung wagen und da was machen, ja dann müssen wir uns komplett drum kümmern und mehr Geld kriegen sie nicht. Also es hat dann noch immer, es hat vielschichtige Gründe und Geld ist dann auch bei solchen Sachen oft ein Problem. Wobei wir ja eben in Nachrichten gehört haben, dass da jetzt vielleicht sogar was passiert, aber erstmal abwarten.
Eine Frage treibt mich noch ein bisschen um, es geht ja sozusagen auch immer um die Internetanschlüsse. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie so relativ große Telekom-Konzernen in Deutschland, was das derzeitige Medienumfeld auch angeht. Also nicht mal aus altruistischen Gründen. Das machen wir jetzt einfach so, jetzt hinzugehen und zu sagen, hier wir bewerfen euch mit Internet und zwar kostenlos wäre doch ein totaler Imagegewinn. Man könnte natürlich auch auf die Gegend kommen, so große Firmen haben vielleicht gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Warum passiert da denn nichts? Also das frage ich mir jetzt gerade wirklich.
Ich meine, es hat eine Presseerklärung der Deutschen Telekom AG gegeben, dass man jetzt den Flüchtlingen großzügig kostenlose Internetanschlüsse bereitstellt. Aber hier in Berlin ist nach meinem Wissensstand nichts davon angekommen. Also bitte korrigiert mich, wenn ihr das anders wisst.
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Es gab Nachfragen dann auch seitens der Freifunker. Und da hieß es dann, man möge bitte die kommunalen Einkaufsstrukturen nutzen. Und das ist ja bekanntermaßen auch eher ein langwieriger Prozess. Und der dann auch zu den langwierigen Prozessen eines so großen Unternehmens passt.
Ich möchte jetzt keine Lanze für die Telekom brechen. Ich hab da auch keine Ahnung, was da jetzt genau wie passiert ist. Aber zum Schluss haben sie dann, auch wenn es lobenswert wäre und schön ist, vielleicht wollen die das ja wirklich gerade machen, aber sie haben dann auch wieder genau die gleichen Probleme, die wir gerade beschrieben haben. Die müssen auch mit jedem Heim einzeln reden. Das Problem ist so hochkomplex, dass du eben nicht mal eben was ausrollen kannst, solange nicht alle wirklich mal an einem Strang ziehen.
Naja, da muss ich jetzt wieder Wasser in den Wein kippen. Und zwar ganz, ganz heftig. Die Betreiber von Heim kommen teilweise jetzt zu uns, Mittwochs zu Freifunk und fragen, wie kann ich denn das bei mir machen? Und da wird dann auch darüber gesprochen, über ihre Erfahrungen. Da gab es diese Ankündigung und dann haben sie sich durchgefragt. Und sie wussten erst mal gar nicht, wer ist denn der Ansprechpartner bei der Telekom? Bei wem spreche ich denn da jetzt vor? Und dann irgendwann gab es von irgendjemanden eine E-Mail. Und dann kam die Antwort zurück, ihr könnt das nicht selber beantragen, das muss das Laggé so machen. Das habe ich jetzt in einem Fall gehört. Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich, das läuft jetzt alles so informell. Na irgendwie, es gab mal eine Presseerklärung. Jemand bei der Telekom oder vielleicht mehrere Leute bei der Telekom haben gedacht, ja das ist eine tolle Sache, das machen wir. Aber letztendlich bleibt es dann eben klein klein und in der Organisation der Verantwortung und dem Kompetenzgerangel vermutlich stecken. Und in der jetzigen Situation zum Beispiel dann zu sagen, ja geht doch zur Laggé so, die muss das beantragen. Die sind völlig überlastet. Die sind ja auch keine Experten für solche Internetgeschichten. Also einfach so eine informelle Hilfe, die jetzt einfach Leute in die Hand nehmen und sagen, ja wir bringen ein paar Router mit und wir machen hier eine Funkstrecke. Sowas geht ganz schnell und geht halt auf dem informellen Weg. Aber sobald eben solche Organisationsstrukturen mit reinkommen, dann werden die Sachen halt wirklich träger. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an den Hurricane Katrina, der New Orleans getroffen hat, wo die Leute hinterher gesagt haben, also die eigentliche Katastrophe war, als die FEMA, die Katastrophenschutzorganisation, da das Handelnsheft in die Hand bekommen hat, da war das nämlich so, da gab es auch, das heißt da nicht Freifunk, sondern freie Netzwerkaktivisten sind hingefahren, haben sich Rad geholt. Ich hab dann per E-Mail geschrieben, Leute, wenn da irgendwie umgestürzte LKWs sind, nehmt die Batterien raus, wenn die noch gut sind, könnt ihr eure Route anschließen und könnt ihr irgendwie behelfsmäßig im Katastrophenfall Netzwerk aufbauen. Und die haben das gemacht. Und die wurden dann irgendwann von der FEMA daran gehindert, dieses System am Laufen zu halten. Also sie sind rein, haben Katastrophenschutz gemacht, haben Infrastruktur aufgebaut und wurden dann von der FEMA daran gehindert, das Gebiet wieder zu betreten.
Na gut, hoffen wir, dass es nicht so weit kommt hier.
Das war uns zum Beispiel in unserer Kampagne auch immer wichtig zu sagen. Wir wollen generell gerne, dass jeder uns unterstützt, von Kirche, über wen auch immer. Aber eben nicht, damit sie jetzt shiny sind und sich darstellen können, sondern sie sollen wirklich helfen. Also die Telekom hätte ja auch einfach mal direkt...
Oder andere große Kommunikation...
Oder andere große Unternehmen einfach mal direkt was machen und später drüber reden. Man hat manchmal das Gefühl, die geben alle erstmal eine Presseerklärung raus. Und warten dann mal ab, was passiert, anstatt erstmal Fakten zu schaffen.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt also sagen, bevor wir... Bevor wir jetzt noch ins große Firmenbashing kommen...
Nein, nein, Nis, das soll es echt nicht sein.
Wir machen jetzt sozusagen die Abschlussrunde, dann darf jeder noch einmal. Aber was ich darin gerne nochmal hätte, ist, dass ihr nochmal sagt, wenn ich jetzt konkret mich daran beteiligen will an diesem Ding, was soll ich machen, wo soll ich hingehen? Elektra-Fingern?
Ja, geht hin zu den Unterkünften und guckt euch die Bedingungen an. Gibt es da schon was? Wenn ihr selber Hilfe haben wollt, wie ihr das aufbauen könnt, dann kommt, wenn ihr jetzt hier in Berlin seid, zu uns in die Seabase am Mittwoch und lasst euch beraten. Und wenn es geht, könnt ihr schon mal prüfen, ob ihr irgendwo da in der Nähe, wenn es nicht selber in der Unterkunft selber geht, einen Anschluss kriegen könnt. Vielleicht gibt es ja freundliche Nachbarn, die, wenn man da einen Freifunkrouter hinstellt, der die Sache mit der Störerhaftung löst, bereit sind, ihren Internetanschluss erstmal zu teilen, sodass erstmal da etwas hinkommt.
Ja, ähm, zu Schluss werden wir sagen, also die Emanzipation und Empowerment von Flüchtlingen ist sehr wichtig, da sie selber dann sich äusen können, was sie lernen oder welche Weg sie in Deutschland gehen wollen. Und ja, also für diese Kampagne wollen wir natürlich Freifunk und Chaos Computer Club Berlin uns hässlich bedanken. Und danke alle, die uns gehört haben. Und danke schonmal für die Unterstützung.
Alles klar, Monique?
Ja, genau, ich schließe mich da im Prinzip Elektra an, wollte nur noch hinzufügen. Wenn ihr nicht in Berlin wohnt, dann schaut mal unter community.freifunk.net Da findet ihr die über 200 deutschlandweiten Freifunkgruppen. Sucht euch die raus, die bei euch in der Nähe ist, kontaktiert die, die beißen nicht, die helfen gern. Und dann geht's los.
Ja, ich würde gerne noch mal eine Lanze brechen, dass man eben die, was wir auch im Titel haben, Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe, dass man Dinge macht, mit den Flüchtlingen redet und nicht immer nur über sie. Und alle noch mal auffordern, sich unserer Kampagne anzuschließen. Wir sind noch offen für Unterstützer, sie bekannt zu machen, sie in den sozialen Netzwerken zu teilen, damit wir dann Refugee Emancipation auch unterstützen können.
Ab 1.10.
Gut, hätten wir auch das geklärt. Traditionell noch zum Schluss der Sendung, wenn hier Chaosradio ist, gibt es immer die nächsten wichtigen Termine im Chaos-Umfeld. Was wird uns da preisgeboten in der nächsten Zeit?
Ja, am kommenden Montag, dem 28.09. haben wir ein Datengarten-Spezial. Ausnahmsweise mal nicht im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, sondern in der Seabase. Da wird Eveline uns etwas erzählen. Der Titel ist From Secret Manoeuvres to Undercover Research. Sehr spannend, ab 20 Uhr. Und dann wird es wie im Vorjahr, zwischen dem 3. und 4. Oktober, das Vintage Computing Festival von der Afra wiedergeben. Das war letztes Jahr sehr beliebt. Alle, die nicht da waren, haben sich sehr geärgert.
Die werden Teilnehmer der Sendung angeschaut.
Auch dieses Jahr wird es abends wieder eine Chiptune-Party geben, ab 21 Uhr. Der Eintritt zum Festival ist kostenlos. Das lohnt sich für alt und jung. Da haben einen Haufen Leute viel Spaß gehabt. Und dann geht es auch schon gleich weiter, am zweiten Dienstag des Monats mit dem regulären Datengarten. Da wird es diesmal um WLAN-Sicherheit gehen und wie man WPA2 umgehen kann.
Da gibt es also ein spannendes Programm. Ich wünsche dir viel Spaß. Vielen Dank Elektra, Lasse, Ima und Monique für's Mitmachen und bei der Sendung dabei sein. Ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle und übergebe dann an Floheil eine Nightflight, der euch wahrscheinlich, wie ich ihn kenne, mit elektrisch verstärkter Gitarrenmusik bewerfen wird. Und mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Markus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen, verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups und macht doch gerne bei der Aktion Arschloch mit.